la sorbonne dans la cour de la sorbonne
400 m
100 élèves des collégiens venus de
différents collèges de toute la région
ile-de-france beaucoup de discours
beaucoup de prises de paroles seront à
l'ordre du jour à partir de 19h30 heure
du début de cette cérémonie le président
de la république emmanuel macron devrait
arriver dans quelques instants il
prendra bien sûr la parole et bien sûr
décernera la légion d'honneur à 6m elle
pâtit à titre posthume en présence de sa
famille quand ils pouvaient pas juste
derrière moi un écran a été mise en
place pour que les personnes et le
public puissent assister à cette
cérémonie cérémonie qui devrait
commencer dans pas longtemps une
cérémonie pour rendre hommage à un
hommage national à ce professeur
d'histoire géographie et bien sûr on
reviendra vers vous dans les prochaines
éditions au cours de ce journal pour
vous décrire l'ensemble de ses abonnés
l'ambiance qu'il ya sur place et les
événements pas clé de cette cérémonie
merci beaucoup bassem pour toutes ces
précisions on vous retrouve à l'issue de
la cérémonie bassin chebbi en direct
devant la sorbonne à paris et du côté de
l' enquête elle est désormais confiée à
un juge antiterroriste pour complicité
d'assassinats terroristes
sept personnes ont été déférées pour
être présenté à un juge antiterroriste
parmi elles des parents d'élèves qui
avaient appelé à la mobilisation contre
le professeur à des connaissances de
l'assaillant et de mineurs des
collégiens qui ont permis au meurtrier
d'identifier l'enseignant écoutez à ce
sujet le procureur antiterroriste il
s'exprimait cet après midi sept
personnes dont deux mineurs ont été
déférés cette nuit dans la perspective
d'une ouverture d'information des chefs
de complicité d'assassinats en relation
avec une entreprise terroriste
votre complicité de tentative
d'assassinât sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste et d' association
de malfaiteurs terroristes en vue de
commettre des crimes d'atteinte aux
personnes parmi ces personnes figurent
deux mineurs âgés de 14 et 15 ans
scolarisé au collège du bois doses
il résulte en effet les investigations
qu'à son arrivée aux abords du collège
vers 14h un moule à quant aux rough
cherché à identifier ses futures
victimes et aborder pour ce faire un
élève en offrant une somme de 300 350
euros le collégien qui accepte
se voyaient remettre une partie de la
somme est resté sur place avec l'auteur
des faits jusqu'à l'arrivée d'autres
camarades
peu avant 16 heures certains se joignent
alors à lui après qu'il a expliqué
l'objet de sa mission il aurait offert
de partager la somme d'argent d'autres
refusaient de résider et pour vivre en
direct l'hommage national à samuel pâtit
qui doit débuter dans 25 minutes environ
maintenant mais avant pour échanger sur
les dernières avancées concernant
l'attentât qui a tué l'enseignant de
conflans sainte honorine nous retrouvons
tout de suite nos invités et avec nous
ce soir alexis poulain éditorialistes
bonsoir à vos côtés éric verhaeghe et
céistes fondateur du blog le courrier
des stratèges bonsoir alexandre del
valle géopolitologue spécialiste des
relations entre l'europe et la turquie
et du monde arabo-musulman et également
avec nous ce soir bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors avant l'hommage à ça mais
elle pâtit votre réaction concernant ces
derniers éléments de l'enquète c'est
donc le parquet national anti terroriste
qui est saisi le procureur à relayer
toute la chaîne qui s'est mise en place
avant l'attentât et deux collégiens de
14 et 15 ans déférés pour avoir désigné
le professeur à l'assaillant ils ont été
soudoyé un par le terroriste contre une
somme d'argent
alexandre del vals comment on en est
arrivé là aujourd'hui
en fait vous savez c'est quelque chose
de mondial n'ont commis le terrorisme au
niveau international il se passe la même
chose dans ce genre de quartier ou de
lycée que ce qui se passe lorsque
quelqu'un est pris en otage ou
assassinés au mali au burkina faso en
irak
c'est très courant il y a plusieurs
chaînes de transmission de l'information
il ya des gens qui sont pas islamistes
mais qui ont été payées pour dire où
habitent plus le toubab quand ses hommes
au burkina faso ou au l'occidentale où
le croiser des camps c'est quelque chose
qui se passe en irak et après le parfois
l'otage est vendu à plusieurs
organisation on retrouve le même
phénomène chez nous finalement les gens
qui sont pas forcément dans la doctrine
mais ils ont donné de l'information un
petit peu parce qu'ils n'aiment pas les
blasphémateurs rêver que dans les
banlieues qu'elle est quelqu'un de la
police de lyon me disait l'autre jour
que il a assisté à un délit à à des
réjouissances il a vu les bandes des
jeunes qui sont pas pour les militants
islamistes mais lisez finalement il a
bien cherché
donc il ya un mélange de vénalité de
voyoucratie parce que y aurait des liens
avec les milieux royoux 1 pour se
procurer et il ya un mélange au type de
n2 radicalisme islamiste mais pas que et
donc c'est quelque chose c'est un modus
vivendi qu'on retrouve à l'international
comme chez nous il se reproduit chez
nous des phénomènes que l'on observe
dans des hauts lieux du djihadisme ça
veut dire aujourd'hui que cette question
on doit la règle et avec nos voisins à
l'international oui mais pas autant que
l'on pourrait le croire pas au sens de
la répression
moi j'ai écrit un article dans valeurs
actuelles récemment où je rappeler
quelque chose que rappelle les militants
modéré laïque du monde musulman mais il
faut le rappeler parce qu'on le dit
jamais assez le blasphème est condamné à
mort est puni de mort dans plusieurs
pays musulmans
il est puni de mort dans la charia même
en france
partout on enseigne la charia il y a des
chapitres sur la façon de tuer les
homosexuels les juifs les mécréants les
païens les prosélytes croiser des
chrétiens ou les blasphémateurs et dans
le monde musulman le grand combat ddd
des intellectuels modérés
vous savez quel est le grand combat
c'est contre le blasphème parce que la
punition de blasphème et ce qui pourrit
la vie du monde musulman et des libres
penseurs
donc on retrouve chez nous quelque chose
qui se passe au niveau de l'islam
mondial pourquoi
regardez ce qui s'est passé à el azhar
ces jours ci la plus grande université
du sionisme c'est pas le djihadisme
c'est l'egypte c'est la plus grande
université depuis des siècles du monde
sunnite
elle vient de dire que
le meilleur moyen pour qu'ils aient pas
ce genre d'assassinât par décapitation
en france ce serait d'interdire tout
blasphème et de pénaliser ce que les 57
pays musulmans de l'organisme de
l'organisation de la conférence
islamique demande depuis les années 90
c'est que ils appellent ça diffamation
l'ordre et lidl que l'on pénalise toute
critique de l'islam et ils vont y
arriver un jour ou l'autre parce que les
modérés vous dise c'est pour pâques et
de meurtres et les djihadistes vous
disent attention on va vos buts et si
vous aussi vous faites si vous pratiquez
le blasphème
donc le problème ne sera réglé que
lorsque les grandes instances de l'islam
du monde entier comme el azhar cesseront
de se référer à une jurisprudence qui
n'a rien à voir avec la foi
je précise la fois du bon musulman les
cinq piliers ne ne passe pas
nécessairement par l'application d'aidé
par exemple en arabie saoudite au lieu
des lieux les lieux saints et pays du
salafisme en crucifie les blasphémateurs
apostats ça se pratique aujourd'hui et
c'est pas des ch
c'est les lieux saints de l'islam le
salafisme il faut savoir qu'on a dit
plein de bêtises dans les médias ces
jours ci c'est pas des hérétiques de
l'islam c'est le quatrième courant
officielle de l'islam sunnite qui est
reconnu par l'ema liquide qui est
reconnu par al azhar et donc l'islam a
besoin d'une réforme pour dépénaliser au
moins qu on ne punit pas de morts ce
genre de choses parce que tant que ce
sera écrit dans les textes qu'on
enseigne dans nos mosquées
comment voulez vous qu'un djihadistes ne
passent pas à l'acte et je termine sur
une chose le patron des frères musulmans
dans toute l'europe qui a pignon sur rue
les organisations comme lui aux iem
musulmans de france où le caire aux
états unis l'oeuvre leur grand juriste
de référence a écrit un livre que vous
pouvez acheter à la fnac et sur amazon
qui n'a jamais été interdit et ils vous
expliquent à musulmans que tu es pour
trois raisons l'adultère l'apostât et
celui qui blasphème donc la sas à
l'assassinât des journalistes de charlie
hebdo est tout à fait charia tic et il
est permis par des angles
lisa sion comme les frères musulmans
qu'ils écrivent noir sur blanc et c'est
pour ça que nous avons dit à la
commission dans lequel sur la
radicalisation du sénat qui a été très
écouté d'ailleurs par l'elysée avec
sifaoui avec d'autres emmanuel razavi
nous avons proposé d'interdire toute
organisation qui se réfère à une ch à
une charia à une lecture de la charia
qui prévoit la peine de mort pour le
blasphème ou la peau stasi pour
continuer avec vous sur l'aspect
international alexandre del vals est ce
que des pays ont contribué selon vous à
la propagation du salafisme en france
mais bien sûr déjà il faut savoir que le
la ligue islamique mondiale qui à 2000
mètres carrés autour de paris dans la
région parisienne et qui à 3000 mètres
carrés à bruxelles où qui a carrément
monopolisé la formation des imams en
espagne donc dans plusieurs pays
européens
elle a pignon sur rue cette organisation
est là l es s et le salafisme officiel
le salafisme je me répète c'est pas des
hérétiques
c'est le courant officielle du
hanbalisme c'est son vrai nom qui est le
courant officielle en arabie saoudite au
qatar
c'est aussi la référence des frères
musulmans et de nombreux salafistes
pakistanais mêmes turcs eux parce que
les salafistes maintenant une ado temps
le monde entier et 7 salaf isation des
esprits elle est littéralement défiguré
le monde musulman jusqu'en indonésie
vous ne reconnaissez plus certains pays
musulmans des vieilles personnes me
disaient qu'elles ont connues
l'indonésie où l'egypte il ya 50 ans les
pays sont méconnaissables
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre temps
les frères musulmans et les salafistes
officielle qui se réfère au même courant
handball it on va pas entrer dans les
détails le jeu est vite mais il se
référant à la même jurisprudence grosso
modo et bien c'est justement eux qui
sont pour un jihad violent
ils veulent rétablir un califat ils ont
une logique suprémacistes ils sont et
ils prônent l'assassinât des juifs des
mécréants bdd des païens et des
blasphémateurs donc vous voyez bien que
ce salafisme il a été déjà instaurées en
europe par des pays qui avaient pignon
sur rue avec leurs diplomaties leur
ambassade
donc il faut bannir tout islamisme qui
prévoit des choses qui sont contraires
au droit de
et à notre droit tout court dans les
pays occidentaux
et ce sera beaucoup plus facile ensuite
d'interdire des prêcheurs parce que là
on a interdit des mosquées ou des
prêcheurs dans certains endroits pour
les motifs d'hygiène parce qu'ils ont
trouvé que ça mais il suffit qu'ils se
mettent aux normes de l'hygiène et ses
mosquées et ses prêcheurs vont
réapparaître dans un mois ou dans deux
mois ou dans six mois maximum
donc il faut bannir comme on a banni le
nazisme à nurenberg il faut bannir
moralement et juridiquement l'islamisme
radical et on oublie aussi le troisième
le communisme les trois grandes
idéologies totalitaires devrait être
bannie au même niveau et ce serait plus
facile ensuite d'interdire les
groupuscules violents qui se réfère à
ces idéologies alors pour revenir à l'
enquête le procureur a également
confirmé que l'assassinât de sa mère
pattie s'inscrivait dans un contexte
d'appel au meurtre a lancé depuis la rue
publication des caricatures de mahomet
par charlie hebdo début septembre eric
verhaeghe
on a beaucoup entendu ces derniers jours
cette volonté montrés massivement ses
caricatures dans les écoles beaucoup de
d'élèves un présent ce soir à l'hommage
de samuel pâtit qu'est ce que vous en
pensez c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui je
pense que nous avons notamment à travers
cette attaque sur un enseignant atteint
un point de rupture d'ordre l'histoire
de la réaction de ce pays al islam est
dans son obsession de la lutte contre
l'islamophobie
je pense que
s'attaquer à un enseignant sans doute
s'attaquer encore à quelque chose qui
représente la république même si on peut
penser que cette image c'est un peu de
10 août avec le temps tu s'aperçoit que
les français ont compris le danger
islamiste sur lequel on alerte beaucoup
alerte depuis plusieurs années en
prêchant dans le vide
d'ailleurs aux dents dans l'indifférence
générale au pouvoir dans l'hostilité
d'un certain nombre de frange de
l'opinion notamment à gauche donc on
s'aperçoit qu'on a atteint ce point de
rupture et qu'aujourd'hui une réaction
en profondeur est en train de se
produire qui ressemble à une prise de
conscience vis-à-vis d'un danger qui a
été systématiquement minimiser ou
sous-estimé mounier par un certain
nombre de deux membres de nombre
d'éléments de l'opinion publique la
question est de savoir aujourd'hui
comment on va se matérialiser cette
prise de conscience et cette réaction
c'est à dire est ce que l'opinion
française est capable de dépasser le
stade de l'émotion ou à ce soir et est
ce que les pouvoirs publics
est-ce que notamment l'état régalien est
capable aujourd'hui de ta d'adopter les
grands éléments les grands axes que
vient de citer alexandre del valle
c'est-à-dire d'abord un renversement
d'alliances internationales puisque
c'est vrai que nous sommes très
dépendants du qatar de l'arabie saoudite
qui sont des grands financeurs salafisme
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes alliés
de ces puissances de ces pays
deux de ces intervenants internationaux
depuis les années 70 notamment dans la
foulée de la guerre en afghanistan est
ce que les pouvoirs publics sont
aujourd'hui capables de renverser cette
alliance est d'imposer aux financeurs
saoudien aux financeurs qatari un
certain nombre de règles du jeu ce qu'il
faut comprendre aujourd'hui ici que
lorsque les qataris ont acheté le paris
saint germain et l'on financer
massivement
c'était une sorte de cheval de troie
c'est à des chevaux de troie qui a fait
le lit du salafisme et de l'islamisme en
france cette dépendance financière qui a
des côtés très bling
bling se traduit aussi par une logique
politique totalement toxiques pour les
libertés publiques et pour l'idéologie
république et nous avons ce sujet en
france aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous
sommes prêts à tirer toutes les
conséquences radicales de la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que nos banlieues sont très
largement investie par une vision
salafistes qui est orthogonale
complètement en conflit avec les grandes
valeurs républicaines qui nous ont faits
qui ont fait notre civilisation depuis
cherché alors justement avant de vous
entendre alexis poulain voici les mots
du chef de l'état relayée par le canard
en le canard enchaîné c'était en privé
après le conseil de défense du 18
octobre regarder l'ennemi est clairement
identifiée il veut notre mort nous
allons donc livrer un combat à mort la
république est bonne fille mais elle ne
se laissera pas violer
si nous ne prenons pas ce combat à bras
le corps viendra le temps difficiles des
affrontements et des milices nous allons
décapiter les organismes islamistes
alexis poule à cet attentat est ce que
vous croyez est ce que vous observez de
la part du politique
un tournant aujourd'hui dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme islamiste
oui c'est à espérer on a l'impression
que enfin la classe politique prend
conscience de l'ampleur du désastre
classe politique hautement coupable
d'avoir été clientéliste d'avoir fermé
les yeux d'avoir accompagné en fait
c'est de ça la fixation des territoires
par intérêt tout personnel et aucun
politique aujourd'hui n'est en mesure de
pointer le doigt vers un autre en disant
qu'il n'a rien fait et y compris le
rassemblement national qui a accepté un
prêt de l'arabie saoudite pour se
financer donc c'est vous dire comment
toute la classe politique française est
dépendante de l'argent des
pétromonarchies et dépendantes et y
compris ici sur le territoire pour
garder ses sièges et ses électeurs d'une
certaine frange de d'un islamisme qui se
présente sous des associations sous des
atours acceptable mais qui derrière
prêche une idéologie totalement
antagonistes avec les valeurs de la
république liberté égalité et fraternité
et ça c'est important que la prise de
conscience soit faite
on aurait aimé que samuel pâtit soit
épargné qu'il soit protégé par la
république quand pharos avait reçu le
signalement du compte twitter de ce
terroriste en juillet peut-être que
certaines certains outils aurait dû être
mis en place à ce moment-là que
l'éducation nationale aussi aurait dû
être vent debout derrière son professeur
en rejetant les appels de ses parents
d'élèves qui cherchait à faire entrer
par la petite porte
leur foi dans l'école de la république
pour imposer une vision de la liberté
d'expression qui n'a rien à voir encore
une fois avec nos lois avec la façon
dont ici nous disons qu'au manque on
critique on les religions nous avons le
droit de blasphémer heureusement donc
tout ça c'est des années voilà de da
laxisme total qui aujourd'hui arrivent à
maturité avec la la la la fois la
récurrence de ses attentats sur notre
sol ce n'est pas la première
décapitation il y avait eu d'autres
attentats de cette façon là ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'on cible un
professeur ou une école c'était à
toulouse c'était meira c'était en 2012
donc vous voyez toutes ces années n'ont
pas été mis à profit pour en finir avec
le poison islamistes au sein de notre
pays de notre république donc si les
politiques en prennent conscience
aujourd'hui et mettre les politiques
qu'il faut et agissent alors tant mieux
on ne va pas s'en plaindre
alors éric verhaeghe alexis poulain
évoqué l'instant l'éducation nationale
dans quelques instants ce sera le temps
du recueillement avec l'hommage à cet
enseignant samuel pâtit le travail des
professeurs également mise à l'honneur
ce soir
est-ce que l'éducation nationale a été
abandonné par les autorités sur cette
question d'islamisation de l'école éric
verhaeghe
non je pense qu' il faudra une fois le
temps de l'émotion et de la delacourt
doléances passer il faudra quand même
commencer un grand inventaire sur ce qui
se passe à l'éducation nationale
alors d'abord disons le aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale c'est une place
forte
les pouvoirs politiques les pouvoirs
publics n'ont plus la légitimité ni la
capacité à intervenir directement sur la
pédagogie la pédagogie qui a fait
sécession dans ce pays il faut le dire
les enseignants aujourd'hui considèrent
qu'ils sont propriétaires de leurs
charges et qu'ils sont seuls maîtres
face à leurs élèves et il y a une vraie
difficulté aujourd'hui à mettre à plat
les questions de pédagogie ce qui va
être intéressant ce sera notamment de
faire l'inventaire de ce qui s'est passé
dans l'académie de versailles autour du
professeur pas de petits puisqu'un
certain nombre de rumeurs ou
d'indications d' indices laissent à
penser que l'académie de versailles a
envoyé des signaux de soutien relatifs
aux parents d'élèves qui se plaignait du
professeur paty et des signaux de
désaveu relatif auprès du professeur
pâtit qui a été convoquée semble-t-il
par un inspecteur qui visiblement lui a
demandé d'expliquer sa façon d'enseigner
l'esprit critique et donc aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet c'est à
dire que moi j'ai lu quand même je suis
allé sur les sites des syndicats
enseignants
je n'ai vu aucun syndicat enseignant et
notamment le snes fsu qui est le
syndicat majoritaire n'a pas pris
position clairement sur le caractère
islamiste de l'attentât donc aujourd'hui
nous avons des syndicats enseignants qui
sont les premiers à protéger d'islamisme
et qui sont en tout cas les premiers à
minorer le danger islamiste est à dire
faux pas de récupération etc
nous avons aujourd'hui besoin de savoir
ce qui se passe à l'éducation nationale
de passer sept les murs de cette
forteresse qui nous interdit de
comprendre comment le savoir est
enseignée dans les écoles et nous avons
besoin de savoir comment l'institution
se positionne par rapport à la lutte
contre l'islamisme et de ce point de vue
il faut qu'on n'entame une havrais
remise à plat de la responsabilité très
profonde en laquelle je crois des
syndicats enseignants dans ce qui s'est
passé je pense qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre la sphère pâtit sans
comprendre qu'il y a des syndicats en
france enseignants qui sont financés par
le contribuable et qui aujourd'hui font
tout pour que la lutte contre
l'islamisme n'est pas lieu et qui passe
aujourd'hui plus de temps à dénoncer
l'islamophobie qu'à défendre les valeurs
de la république et cette phase là elle
doit s'ouvrir très vite une fois le
temps du recueillement passé je vous
propose justement à ce sujet d'écouter
un témoignage c'est celui de rodrigo
arenas et le vice président de la fcpe
c'est la première association de parents
d'élèves et il a reçu un signalement
vendredi dernier faisant état d'un père
extrêmement énervé après la publication
en classe d'une caricature de mahomet
regardez c'est que nous avons signé les
cela au maire au maire pourquoi parce
que nous avons estimé que ce qui était
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux étaient
suffisamment probants pour nous craindre
un trouble à l'ordre public et dans
notre pays ceux qui sont en charge de
l'ordre public dans une commune ça
s'appelle le maire qui ensuite
évidemment travail avec les services de
police pour éviter les débordements quel
qu'il soit c'est pour cela que j'ai fait
prévenir le maire qui m'a fait a appelé
dans la journée pour me dire que toutes
les dispositions ont été prises sur la
ville de conflans sainte honorine
suite à ça ces messages qui circulait
sur les réseaux sociaux et que
l'éducation nationale parfaitement au
fait des deux de cette situation mettez
tout à disposition toutes les procédures
normales
en tout cas pas les procédures qui
existent pour ce type de cas c'est que
nous avons signé les cela aux maires des
six poules a effectivement vous vous
rejoignez les propos d'eric verhaeghe
qui d'irak qui disait que une fois le
recueillement à l'émotion terminé il
faudra s'interroger aussi sur la
position des syndicats
l'éducation nationale il faudra
s'interroger sur la position de tout le
monde bien sûr cette question de la
place des parents dans l'école c'est pas
neuf là encore c'est le progressisme des
années 80 70 comment faire que l'école
soit soit ouverte sur les parents mais
ça ne veut pas dire que les parents font
la loi dans l'école
quant aux syndicats ils sont là pour
protéger les travailleurs donc on
aimerait qu'il protège les travailleurs
ce que j'ai vu c'est beaucoup de
professeurs de syndiqués ou non
très en colère par rapport à la
commisération qu'il y avait maintenant
sur le métier de professeur alors que on
tire à boulet rouge
en temps normal sur ces enseignants trop
feignants qui passent leur temps en
vacances etc etc
rappelez vous on les accusait d'avoir
pris en otage les copies du bac parce
qu'il se plaignait justement il
critiquer la façon dont l'éducation
nationale était gérée mais une fois
encore l'éducation nationale comme
toutes les administrations géré par une
boursouflure administratif qui fait que
finalement c'est là où on a le plus
besoin de ressources qu'il n'y en a pas
les professeurs on a besoin de davantage
de professeurs on a besoin de moins
d'élèves dans les classes on a besoin de
faire en sorte que l'éducation soit de
qualité
mais qu'est ce qui se passe on a des
rectorats on a tout cette boursouflure
administrative qui fait que ce
management par la peur par la protection
des uns des autres on se renvoie
toujours la patate chaude l'idée c'est
d'être jamais responsable jamais
coupable donc on fait tout pour se
protéger que ce soit l'inspecteur puis
le recteur etc etc
dans l'éducation nationale comme dans
beaucoup d'organisation mais là c'est
particulièrement flagrant
les professeurs sont seuls face aux
élèves sont seuls face aux parents et
est rarement rarement très rarement ils
ont le soutien du directeur
d'établissement et de la machine
éducation nationale donc il ya un vrai
travail à faire sur la façon dont tous
toute cette éducation doit être revue
parce que quand même l'éducation
nationale c'est le projet qui fonde
aussi la république sociale sait faire
que tous les citoyens puissent avoir les
moyens de grottes de se grandir
intellectuellement de se cultiver avoir
les moyens pour leur futur préparer leur
futur aujourd'hui la faillite et les
nombreuses
à de nombreuses de nombreux échelons et
ça ne fait que ça ne fait que continuer
et je crois que c'est important que au
delà de ce moment où tout le monde
s'arrête pense aux professeurs à tous
les professeurs que nous avons eues qui
nous ont permis de devenir qui nous
sommes aujourd'hui
eh bien il ya une politique derrière qui
va débloquer les moyens alors je sais ça
fait beaucoup de moyens il en faut pour
l'hôpital you faut pour l'éducation
nationale
il en faut aussi pour la police mais
voilà ces années qui ont été celles du
moins d'état ce qui ont été celles du
démantèlement de l'état social de la
république sociale elles doivent cesser
aujourd'hui et au delà de la réponse qui
va être une réponse sécuritaire bien
entendu il y a une réponse de long terme
qui est celle de la devise de la
république celle de l'égalité de la
liberté de la fraternité qui passera par
une éducation nationale qui a les moyens
d'éduquer qu'ils aient les moyens de
faire en sorte que ont créé des citoyens
conscients et pas des bêtes comme ce
tchétchène qui a 18 ans à une bouillie
dans la tête qui lui permet de décapiter
un professeur simplement parce qu'il a
montré des caricatures alexis poulain
eric verhaeghe
vous restez avec nous on va remercier
alexandre del valle qui a dû nous
quitter
merci à lui on va tout de suite retrouvé
bassem chebbi devant la sorbonne
quelques à quelques minutes du début de
la cérémonie d'hommage à cet enseignant
qui s'est fait assassiner donc à
conflans sainte honorine
bassem chebi donc la cérémonie doit
débuter dans quelques instants
effectivement olivella que la cérémonie
devrait débuter dans quelques instants
le président de la république est
attendu dans la cour de la sorbonne pour
un discours qui devrait durer une
quinzaine de minutes en hommage à samuel
pâtit ce professeur mais la cérémonie a
commencé un petit peu plus tôt à huis
clos c'était la volonté de la famille
une cérémonie à huis clos entre le
président de la république et la famille
de samuel pâtit afin de lui remettre la
légion d'honneur à titre posthume une
volonté de la famille de ne pas faire
que cette ce sujet cela en public donc
ils ont voulu le faire
avis clos le président de la république
ne devrait pas tarder à arriver dans la
cour de la sorbonne pour un discours
d'une quinzaine de minutes il est
attendu par 400 invités beaucoup de
politiques beaucoup d'élus ont fait le
déplacement il y à monsieur le drian ou
encore edouard philippe on a pu voir
anne hidalgo ou encore l'ancien
président jean françois hollande ne
présenta en public devrait arriver dans
quelques instants l'orchestré de la
garde républicaine est présente sur dans
la cour de la sorbonne qui devrait jouer
en l'hommage de samuel patine cérémonie
nationale ici à la sorbonne nous sommes
toujours devant le parvis qui est devenu
le noir demande en très peu de temps
beaucoup de journalistes peut aussi de
simples badauds de simples citoyens qui
sont venus rendre hommage à ce
professeur mais si on reviendra vers
vous et olives et dans quelques instants
contre le président de la république
assure entrera dans mac os de la
sorbonne pour la deuxième partie de cet
hommage national à samuel pâtit merci va
sam shemie on se retrouve effectivement
à la fin de cette cérémonie est
justement le président de la république
emmanuel macron on l'a vu vient
d'arriver dans la cour de la sorbonne
pour cet hommage à samuel patil a serré
beauty donc des butins dans la cour de
la sorbonne emmanuel macron va prononcer
notamment un discours un centre et tout
à l'heure sur la vie de l'enseignant
assassiné par un terroriste on le voit
aux côtés de nombreux ministres en
écoutant
[Musique]
allez
nous
[Musique]
je sais
pour tous
[Musique]
souley
hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mené
six semaines
m
[Musique]
là dessus
non la cérémonie non
[Musique]
alors que
le cercueil de samuel pas t'y arrives
dans la cour d'honneur de la sorbonne
porté par les gardes républicains
accompagné par la chanson one du groupe
irlandais
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
je
ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte aux instituteurs et
institutrices de jean jaurès va être lui
maintenant par un ami de samuel pâtir et
enseignants
[Musique]
chef de l'état entouré de son premier
ministre et de ses ministres
sont rassemblés françois hollande
également l'ancien président de la
république français présent pour cet
hommage c'est donc un ami de sa mère
pattie qui prend la parole pour lire le
texte aux instituteurs et institutrices
de jean jaurès nous te saluons camarades
nous tes amis tes frères et soeurs de
classes préparatoires de l'université
des premiers pas dans le métier de
professeur d'histoire et de géographie
le 15 janvier 1888 dans la dépêche de
toulouse jean jaurès écrit aux
instituteurs et institutrices quelques
conseils pour que les élèves apprennent
à être autonome à réfléchir à se forger
une opinion conseil auquel samuel qui a
été fidèle vous tenez dans vos mains
l'intelligence et l'âme des enfants
vous êtes responsable de la patrie les
enfants qui vous sont confiés n'auront
pas seulement à écrire et à déchiffrer
une lettre à lire une enseigne au coin
d'une rue à faire une addition et une
multiplication
ils sont français ils doivent connaître
la france sa géographie et son histoire
son corps et son âme
ils seront citoyens
ils doivent savoir ce qu'est une
démocratie libre quel droit leur confère
qu'elle de voir leur impose la
souveraineté de la nation
enfin et seront homme et il faut qu'ils
aient une idée de l'homme
il faut qu'ils sachent quelle est la
racine de toutes nos misères l'égoïsme
aux formes multiples il faut qu'ils
sachent quel est le principe de notre
grandeur la fierté unis à la tendresse
il faut leur montrer la grandeur de la
pensée il faut leur enseigner le respect
et le culte de l'âme en éveillant en eu
le sentiment de l'infini qui est notre
joie est aussi notre force
car c'est par lui que nous trions feront
du mal de l'obscurité et de la mort
sachant bien lire les colliers trek est
très curieux aurait bien vite avec sept
ou huit livres choisis une idée très
générale il est vrai mais très hot de
l'espèce humaine de la structure du
monde de l'histoire propre de la terre
dans le monde qui roule propre de la
france dans l'humanité le maître doit
intervenir pour aider ce premier travail
de l'esprit
il n'est pas nécessaire qu'ils disent
beaucoup qu'il fasse de l'ombre le sont
il suffit que tous les détails qui leur
donnera un concours nettement un tableau
d'ensemble de ce que l'on sait de
l'homme primitif à l'homme d'aujourd'hui
quel prodigieuse transformation et comme
il est aisé à l'instituteur et aux
professeurs en quelques traits de faire
sentir à l'enfant l'effort inouïe de la
pensée humaine
je dis donc au maître et aux professeurs
pour me résumer lorsque d'une part vous
aurez appris aux enfants à lire à fond
et lorsque d'autre part en quelques
causerie familière et grave
vous leur aurez parler de grandes choses
qui intéressent la pensée et la
conscience humaine
vous aurez sans peine en quelques années
fait oeuvre complète d'éducateurs dans
chaque intelligence il y aura un sommet
et ce jour là bien des choses changeront
adieu samu
christophe cape mano donc à un ami de
samuel pâtit qui vient de lire un texte
de jean jaurès aux instituteurs un texte
rédigé le 15 janvier 1888 un poème du à
samuel de goven servent à être lui
maintenant par un enseignant à samuel
pâtit paraît qu'on s'habitue aux larmes
de la nation ce matin on s'est tu sous
le coup de l'émotion paraît qu'on
s'habitue
quand la femme est légion tous ces
hommes abattus pour les traits d'un
crayon paraît qu'on s'habitue à défendre
à tout prix les trois mots qu'on a lues
au fronton des mairies paraît qu'on
s'habitue
quand on manque de savoir par chance on
a tous eu un professeur d'histoire paris
qu'on s'habitue à la pire barbarie mais
jamais on ya cru et pas plus aujourd'hui
paraît qu'on s'habitue aux horreurs
qu'on vit là mais l'innocent qu'on tue
on ne s'habitue pas
[Musique]
marie marie cuir au professeur
d'histoire géographie elle même vient
donc de lire le poème à samuel de goven
sert un élève doit maintenant lire la
lettre d'albert camus à son instituteur
louis germain
le jour où l'écrivain a reçu le prix
nobel de littérature
lettre de camus à son instituteur louis
germain écrite le jour où il a reçu le
prix nobel de littérature 19 novembre
cher monsieur germans g laisser
s'éteindre un peu le bruit qui m'a
entouré tous ces jours ci avant de venir
vous parler un peu de tout mon coeur on
vient de me faire un bien trop grand
honneur que je n'ai ni à rechercher ni
sollicitée mais quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle
ma première pensée après ma mère a été
pour vous sans vous sans cette man
affectueuse que vous avez tendu au petit
enfant pauvre que je su que j'étais sans
votre enseignement et votre exemple rien
de tout cela ne serait arrivé je ne me
fais pas un monde de cette sorte
d'honneur mais celui là est du moins une
occasion pour vous dire ce que vous avez
été et est toujours pour moi et pour
vous assurer que vos efforts votre
travail et le coeur généreux que vous y
mettiez sont toujours vivants chez un de
vos petits écoliers qui malgré l'âge n'a
pas cessé d'être pour votre
reconnaissance élèves
je vous embrasse de toutes mes forces
albert camus
dalia élève de 14 ans en seconde au
lycée massillon à paris dans le
quatrième viens de lire la lettre
d'albert camus à son instituteur louis
jerram à une lettre écrite le jour où
l'écrivain a reçu le prix nobel de
littérature
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron doit
lui maintenant s'exprimer dans quelques
minutes
[Applaudissements]
quelques minutes pour clore donc cet
hommage à samuel pâtit assassiné
sauvagement vendredi dernier à conflans
sainte honorine
alexis poulain une réaction à tous et
ses textes forts qui ont été lus en
quelques mots avant la prise de parole
du chef de l'état oui c'était des textes
très bien choisis je crois pour montrer
l'importance était professeur dans la
vie de dans nos vies parce qu'ils sont
importants oui nous montrer d'autres
choses pour nous ouvrir le monde pour
nous faire comprendre qu'il est vaste et
que à prendre est un chemin de vie et
ces textes là de camus
et d'autres ont été ont été bien lui et
c'est un hommage fort pour on va écouter
le pâtisson professeurs on va écouter le
chef de l'état
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
ce soir je n'aurai pas de mot pour
évoquer la lutte contre l'islamisme
politique radicale qui mène jusqu'au
terrorisme les mots je les ai vu le mal
je les nommer les actions nous les avons
décidé nous les avons durci nous les
mènerons jusqu'au bout ce soir je ne
parlerai pas du cortège de terroristes
de leurs complices et de tous les lâches
qui ont commis est rendu possible cet
attentat je ne parlerai pas de ceux qui
ont livré son nom aux barbares ils ne le
méritent pas de nom eux n'ont même plus
ce soir je ne parlerai pas davantage de
l'indispensable unité que toutes les
françaises et tous les français
ressentent
elle est précieuse et oblige tous les
responsables à s'exprimer avec justesse
et à agir avec exigence non
ce soir je veux parler de votre fils je
veux parler de votre frère
de votre oncle
de celui que vous avez aimé de ton père
ce soir je veux parler de votre collègue
de votre professeur tomber parce qu'il
avait fait le choix d'enseignés
assassiné parce qu'il avait décidé
d'apprendre à ses élèves à devenir
citoyens à prendre les devoirs pour les
remplir à prendre les libertés pour les
exercer
ce soir
je veux vous parler
de samuel pâtit samuel pâtit aimer les
livres le savoir plus que tout son
appartement était une bibliothèque c'est
plus beau cadeau des livres pour
apprendre
[Musique]
il aimait les livres pour transmettre à
ses élèves comme à ses proches
la passion de la connaissance le goût de
la liberté
après avoir étudié l'histoire à lyon et
avoir envisagé devenir chercheur il
avait emprunté la voie tracée par vous
séparant instituteur et directeur
d'école à moulins en devenant chercheurs
en pédagogie comme il aimait à se
définir en devenant professeur aussi
ne pouvait-on trouver meilleur endroit
que la sorbonne notre lieu de savoir
universel depuis + de vie siècle le lieu
de l'humanisme pour que la nation puisse
lui rendre cet hommage
samuel bâti aimé passionnément enseigner
et il le fit si bien dans plusieurs
collèges et lycées jusqu'à celui de
conflans sainte honorine
nous avons tous ancrés dans nos coeurs
dans nos mémoires le souvenir d'un
professeur qui a changé le cours de
notre existence
vous savez cet instituteur qui nous a
appris à lire à compter à nous faire
confiance
cet enseignant qui nous a pas seulement
a pris un savoir mais nous a ouvert un
chemin par un livre un regard un instant
passé par sa considération
samuel pâtit
était de ceux-là de ses professeurs que
l'on n'oublie pas de ces passionnés
capables de passer des nuits à apprendre
l'histoire des religions pour mieux
comprendre ses élèves leurs croyances
de ses humbles qui se remettait mille
fois en question comme pour ce cours sur
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
conscience qu'il préparait depuis
juillet encore l'été dernier à moulins à
vos côtés et des doutes qu'il partageait
par exigence
par délicatesse
samuel pâtit incarner au fond le
professeur dont rêvait jaurès dans cette
lettre aux instituteurs qui vient d'être
lu la fermeté unis à la tendresse celui
qui montre la grandeur de la pensée
enseigne le respect donne à voir ce
qu'est la civilisation
celui qui s'était donné pour tâche de
faire des républicains alors reviennent
comme en écho les mots de fer non
buisson pour faire un républicain
écrivait-il il faut prendre l'être
humain si petit et si humble qu'il soit
et lui donner l'idée qu'il faut penser
par lui-même qu'il ne doit ni foi ni
obéissance à personne que c'était lui de
chercher la vérité et non pas à la
recevoir toute faite d'un mètre d'un
directeur d'un chef
quel qu'il soit
faire des républicains
c'était le combat de samuel pâtit et si
cette tâche aujourd'hui peut paraître
titanesque notamment là où la violence
l'intimidation
parfois la résignation prennent le
dessus
elle est plus essentielle plus actuelle
que jamais ici en france nous aimons
notre nation sa géographie ses paysages
et son histoire sa culture et ses
métamorphoses son esprit et son coeur et
nous voulons l'enseigné à tous nos
enfants ici en france nous aimons le
projet tout à la fois
therrien et universel que porte la
république son ordre et ses promesses
chaque jour recommencer alors oui dans
chaque école dans chaque collège dans
chaque lycée
nous redonnerons aux professeurs le
pouvoir de faire des républicains la
place et l'autorité qui leur reviennent
nous les formerons les considérons comme
il se doit nous les soutiendrons nous
les protégerons autant qu'il le faudra
dans l'école comme hors de l'école les
pressions
l'abus d'ignorance et d'obéissance que
certains voudraient instaurer n'ont pas
leur place chez nous
je voudrais que ma vie et ma mort serve
à quelque chose avait il dit un jour
comme par prescience
alors pourquoi samuel futile tués
pourquoi
vendredi soir j'ai d'abord cru à la
folie aléatoire à l'arbitraire absurde
une victime de plus du terrorisme
gratuit après tout il n'était pas la
cible principale des islamistes il ne
faisait qu enseigner il n'était pas
l'ennemi de la religion dont ils se
servent ils avaient lu le coran est
respecté ses élèves quelles que soient
leurs croyances
il s'intéressait à la civilisation
musulmane non
tout au contraire samuel pâtit fut tué
précisément pour tout cela parce qu'il
incarnait la république qui renaît
chaque jour dans les salles de classe la
liberté qui se transmet et se perpétue à
l'école samuel bâti fille tuée parce que
les islamistes veulent notre futur et
qu'ils savent qu'avec des héros
tranquille tels que lui ils ne l'auront
jamais eu
c'est par les fidèles et les mécréants
samuel pâtit ne connaissait que des
citoyens eux se repaissent de
l'ignorance lui croyait dans le savoir
eux cultivent la haine de l'autre
lui voulait sans cesse en voir le visage
découvrir les richesses de l'altérité
samuel pâtit fut la victime de la
conspiration funeste de la bêtise du
mensonge de la malle gamme de la haine
de l'autre de la haine de ceux que
profondément existentiellement nous
sommes samuel patty est devenu vendredi
le visage de la république de notre
volonté de briser les terroristes de
réduire les islamistes de vivre comme
une communauté de citoyens libres dans
notre pays
le visage de notre détermination à
comprendre à apprendre a continué
d'enseigner à être libre
car nous continuerons professeurs nous
défendrons la liberté que vous enseignez
si bien et nous porterons haut à la
laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs nous
offriront toutes les chances que la
république doit à toute sa jeunesse sans
discrimination aucune
nous continuerons professeurs avec tous
les instituteurs et professeurs de
france nous enseignerons l'histoire ces
gloires comme ces vicissitudes nous
feront découvrir la littérature la
musique
toutes les oeuvres de l'âme et de
l'esprit
nous aimerons de toutes nos forces le
débat les arguments raisonnables les
persuasion aimable nous aimerons la
science et ses controverses comme vous
nous cultiverons la tolérance comme vous
nous chercherons à comprendre sans
relâche et à comprendre encore davantage
cela qu'on voudrait éloigné de nous nous
apprendrons l'humour la distance
nous rappellerons
que nos libertés ne tiennent que par la
fin de la haine et de la violence par le
respect de l'autre
nous continuerons professeurs
et tout au long de leur vie les
centaines de jeunes gens que vous avez
formé exerceront cet esprit critique que
vous leur avez appris peut-être certains
d'entre eux deviendront ils enseignants
à leur tour alors ils formeront des
jeunes citoyens à leur tour ils feront
aimer la république
ils feront comprendre notre nation nos
valeurs notre europe dans une chaîne des
temps qui ne s'arrêtera pas nous
continuerons oui
ce combat pour la liberté et pour la
raison donc vous êtes désormais le
visage parce que nous vous le devons
parce que
nous nous le devons parce qu'en france
professeur les lumières ne s'éteignent
jamais vive la république
vive la france
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron vient
donc d'achever son discours en hommage à
samuel pâtit l'enseignement tués
vendredi dernier à conflans sainte
honorine tué pour avoir montré des
caricatures en classe
l'hommage à paris a eu lieu dans la cour
de la sorbonne le chef de l'état qui se
recueillent actuellement devant la
dépouille de samuel pâtit pour une
minute de silence
[Applaudissements]
m
orchestre à cordes de la garde
républicaine
[Musique]
nous
et
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la garde républicaine qui vient donc de
jouer la marseillaise le chef de l'état
qui se recueille devant la dépouille de
samuel pâtit
chef de l'état entouré du premier
ministre jean castex de tous ces
ministres de l'ancien président de la
république françois hollande est bien
évidemment de la famille du défunt
[Applaudissements]
cette cérémonie d'hommage à samuel pâtit
s'achève le cercueil va sortir dans
quelques instants accompagné par la
symphonie numéro 3 de mozart on voit les
gardes républicains
arrivés dans la cour de la sorbonne lieu
hautement symbolique choisi ce soir pour
cet hommage à samuel pâtit
[Musique]
un hommage donc qui s'achève avec la
symphonie numéro 3 de mozart
[Musique]
jouée par l'orchestré à cordes de la
garde républicaine
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était de ces professeurs que l'on
n'oublie pas a dit emmanuel macron dans
son discours prononcé il ya quelques
instants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cérémonie d'hommage nom de samuel
bâti qui s'achève
[Musique]
avec le départ de son cercueil porté par
les gendarmes de la garde républicaine
un hommage qui a été voulue dans la cour
de la sorbonne
par le chef de l'état mais aussi sa
famille un lieu hautement symbolique
choisie
en accord avec la famille du défunt vous
l'avez vu 400 personnes étaient conviées
ce soir les ministres du gouvernement
mais aussi l'ancien chef de l'état
françois hollande
également gérard larcher le président du
sénat
et juste avant cette cérémonie emmanuel
macron a remis la légion d'honneur à
l'enseignant à titre posthume le
cercueil donc de sa belle pratique qui
t'a à l'instant la cour de la sorbonne
et pour eux revenir sur cette cérémonie
sur cet hommage à sève elle pâtit nous
allons tout de suite retrouvé sur place
notre reporter sam shemie alors pendant
tant les applaudissements les personnes
présentes ce soir dans la cour de la
sorbonne et aux alentours d'un tel
schéma
effectivement olivier une foule qui
continue d'applaudir le départ de la
bogossitude
on a vu le très émue une grosse
différents discours que ce soit le
discours du meilleur ami de ce
professeur roller d'une élève et puis
nous discours du chef de l'état il
apprend qui est revenue sur les valeurs
de la république sur l'importance de
l'enseignement
et d'expression il a rendu hommage à ce
professeur départ les otages ont rendu
hommage à l'ensemble du corps enseignant
aux français pour le travail qu'il fait
jour après jour et la les revenus sur
cette invocation ce métier à former des
esprits les hosties de demain à savoir
tous ces jeunes et les enfants
des écoles des collèges ou encore un
délit c'est la dépouille de samuel patty
est en train de quitter la cour de la
sorbonne sa dépouille est arrivée
quelques instants avant le discours du
chef de l'état pour cet hommage national
pour ce professeur d'histoire géographie
de conflans sainte honorine
sassine est sauvagement et c'était
vendredi dernier un hommage très
solennelle
le voir l' orchestre d'orchestre de la
garde républicaine mais en train de
jouer un morceau de mozart qui
accompagne le départ de la dépouille de
samuel pâtit ici comme on peut voir la
place est noire de monde beaucoup
d'anonymes ont voulu rendre hommage à ce
professeur en assistante ici à la
rediffusion sur écran géant de la
cérémonie qui se trouve à l'intérieur je
vous rappelle que 400 invités sont
présents le chef de l'état bien sûr
ainsi que l'ensemble de son gouvernement
et d'anciennes personnalités politiques
françaises comme le l'ancien président
françois hollande aussi présents ici la
première partie de la cérémonie a eu
lieu à huis clos avec la famille de
samuel pâtit pour remettre la légion
d'honneur à titre posthume à ce
professeur d'histoire géographie une
cérémonie qui s'est voulue à huis clos
de selon les
les dires et selon la volonté de la
famille qui n'a pas voulu rendre ce
moment de la cérémonie publique donc là
pour l'instant
la dépouille quitte la sorbonne et puis
comme vous pouvez voir juste derrière
moi des applaudissements d'aidé s'ils en
ont subi de silence a été respectée ici
pour rendre hommage à son professeur le
gouvernement avait annoncé que son fils
de 5 ans de pupille de la nation
à l'issue de cet événement tragique
arrivé à ce professeur d'histoire donc
une émotion a sévit ici la cmu qui vient
de toucher à sa fin comme vous voyez
mais beaucoup de monde reste encore ici
à présent et encore une fois des
applaudissements on a pu voir beaucoup
d'applaudissements on applique
d'entretenir avec les différentes
personnes qui étaient présentes et qui
nous ont déclaré qu'il était important
pour elle de venir soutenir la famille
de samuel patine et surtout un message
envoyé aux terroristes à savoir que ici
en france nous resterons très attaché
aux valeurs de la république à la
liberté d'expression à la liberté
d'enseigner surtout voilà les différents
témoignages qu'on a pu avoir ce tout au
long de cette cérémonie
ici c'est aux abords de la sorbonne
merci beaucoup bassem bassem vous restez
avec nous on va vous retrouver tout à
leur bassin chebbi en direct de la
sorbonne alors pour revenir sur cette
cérémonie
daumas qu à ça mais elle pâtit que vous
avez pu vivre en direct sur rt france
vous avez pu entendre ces témoignages
poignants le discours du président eh
bien on va en parler tout de suite avec
nos invités
et nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
alexis poulain vous avez vécu
l'événement avec nous en direct je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes re
bonsoir nous ont rejoint kevin bossou
est professeur d'histoire en
seine-saint-denis bonsoir à vos côtés
jean-pierre colombiès porte-parole
associations de police une pénis et
l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants bonsoir alors kévin bossuet
c'est donc l'un de vos collègues que la
france a l'un de vos collègues que la
france a rendu hommage ce soir vous êtes
comme lui professeur d'histoire dans
quel état d'esprit êtes vous ce soir ce
soir je suis horriblement peiné je suis
également règlement choqué parce que
comme vous l'avez dit c'est un de mes
collègues qui est mort c'est un confrère
qui est mort qui est mort pour avoir
fait quoi pour avoir du sart noirs de la
république pour avoir amorcé dans sa
classe notamment un débat sur la liberté
d'expression et moi ce que j'aimerais
bien c'est qu'il se passe quelque chose
après tout tous ces blablas que l'on
entend sur les plateaux de télévision
tous ces hommages que l'on entend
initier là j'aimerais bien qu'on agisse
notamment contre cette montée de l'islam
politique au sein de l'école de la
république
cela fait des années que l'on dénonce la
montée de l'islam hisser là j'espère
qu'on se rencontre à quel point sur
certains territoires
l'école est gangréné notamment par cette
idéologie mortifère qui est le
totalitarisme islamiste et pour cela il
faut faire en sorte que les enseignants
ne reste plus seul plus seuls face à
leurs élèves plus seul face à certains
parents en effet qu'ils font de
l'entrisme et surtout que la hiérarchie
soutienne enfin ces enseignants c'est
nous ou une armoire de la république qui
faisons vivre la république au sein des
territoires perdus c'est nous qui sommes
devant les élèves pourrait essayer
d'inculquer les valeurs de respect les
valeurs de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité et les valeurs de laïcité
donc il faut que deux nouveaux les
français nous fassent confiance de
nouveau les français nous soutiennent
dans cette tâche qui est ardue dans
cette tâche qui aujourd'hui peut nous
coûter la vie jean-pierre colombie
vous êtes policier vous avez des
collègues vous aussi qui ont été
victimes morts sous les balles des
terroristes
ce soir est ce que la police elle a les
moyens d'observer de prévenir ce qui
peut se passer dans les écoles le le
drame qui s'est passé vendredi
quel est votre sentiment ce soir alors
je vais être très claire et directe
on est là pour se parler très clairement
et très franchement les moyens aucun
aucun tout simplement parce que le mal
auquel on est on est confronté est une
véritable gangrène un véritable cancer
qui se répand dans toutes les strates de
la population
on va pas se cacher derrière son petit
doigt sur quoi on est confronté dépasse
la simple notion de réseau terroriste
comme on l'a connu dans données dans les
mois les années passées donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est très
prégnant qui est insidieux qui se répand
partout pour reprendre conforter de
propos qu'il avait tenus pour savoir
quand même qu'on a des classes aussi on
a des gamins de 14 15 ans qui font
régner la terreur dans des classes au
nom d'un islam qui le programment
proclame haut et fort et ce ne sont pas
des terroristes en soit ce sont
simplement les vecteurs d'une propagande
et d'une idéologie insidieuse et là qui
est très très prégnante moi ce que je
voudrais ajouter quand même parce que là
il ya un sentiment qui ressent qu'il
ressentirait très fort à la fois de
colère de grande colère et d'écoeurement
pourquoi parce que c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que ça a commencé cette
situation jr au tout est parti d'une
certaine manière de manière très
exacerbée en 2012 avec mes rares qui va
quand même tué des enfants qui n'a tué
des militaires déjà à l'époque
souvenez-vous nous a rabattu les
oreilles comme quoi c'était symbolique
et je vous en passe et des meilleurs sur
les discours des plus hypocrites et des
plus lamentables qu'il soit et puis il y
avait d autres massacres
bien évidemment charlie hebdo le
bataclan on pourrait continuer par le
massacre de magnanville le couple de
policiers égorgé à leur domicile devant
un enfant de 5 ans
si on veut des symboles on va en trouver
et croyez moi on a ce chef d'entreprise
qui a été égorgé des quatre décapités
par son employé ensuite nous avons eu
ces deux jeunes femmes une infirmière
une étudiante en médecine égorgé en
plein coeur de la gare saint charles à
marseille donc les symboles ils sont là
ils étaient déjà là ils sont toujours là
aujourd'hui on a un drame c'est un
enseignant donc en fait on a une ligne
ininterrompue de symboles de parents
d'enfants parce que mes race attaquant
des enfants de 2 ans et le 10 ans et que
très glorieux effectivement on a des
enseignants un enseignant aujourd'hui
des journalistes des militaires des
policiers
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut de plus qu'est
ce qu'il faut de plus pour prendre des
mesures courageuses radical dans un
immense concert de de l'équipe qui est
dérisoire à mes yeux de tous ses
discours les ai déjà entendu ne
passeront pas c'est la guerre contre le
terrorisme et l'intégrisme question
sérieux des mesures à prendre il y en a
et il y aura en prendre deux mains 110
ans ça sent vraiment avoir un débat
après il suffirait de modifier des
points très particulier du code de
procédure pénale par exemple pour
accélérer et fluidifier les procédures
qui aujourd'hui ont été volontairement
alourdi par ce pouvoir politique qui
aujourd'hui nous jouent l'air de la
compassion universelle c'est absolument
scandaleux
je vous le dis avec beaucoup de colère
avec beaucoup de force ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui est le résultat de
dizaines d'années d'abandon de ce qu'est
l'état dans ce pays et le l'effondrement
du système colère du système scolaire ou
plutôt son attaque frontale aujourd'hui
n'est qu une résultante de ce que nous
visions de ce que nous voyons de ce que
nous observons dans certains quartiers
dans certains pans entiers de notre pays
l'état à reculer l'état recule l'état
démissionne l'état abandonne ses
enseignants comme il abandonne son
personnel soignant comme il abandonne
ses policiers parce qu'il a le regard
ailleurs vous savez je suis pas bien sûr
qu'on s'associe à la peine au drame que
connais cette famille mais il faut
prendre du recul et ne pas se contenter
de discours de commémoration de deux
marches blanches de petites tensions qui
sont déposés aux endroits symboliques
ça suffit il faut aller au delà des
symboles purement visuel des mots de
cette avalanche de mots il faut des
actions et de véritables actions et je
peux vous assurer que le mode d'emploi
qui permettrait à minima de s'attaquer à
ceux qui ont déclaré la guerre à la
république parce que c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
c'est d'une bière les outils sont là
appliquons les donnons nous la peine de
les appliquer deux mois donnons nous que
les politiques prennent leurs
responsabilités ce pour quoi ils sont
mandatés par le peuple dollar
on va bientôt venir donc on va y revenir
effectivement sur les actions à mener
mais avant alexis poule a on vient
d'entendre la colère à la fois d'un
professeur la colère d'un policier vous
êtes un fin observateur de la vie
politique depuis plusieurs années
maintenant comment aujourd'hui est ce
que vous expliquez vous comprenez
finalement que les politiques ont fermé
les yeux sur cette question est ce qu'on
peut le dire aujourd'hui
oui ils ont fermé les yeux sur cette
question ils ont été totalement
lamentable et tous les politiques ont eu
soin des visées clientéliste avec des
courants islamistes même gérald darmanin
participer à des événements du ccf qui
dissout aujourd'hui associations qui
disent tous aujourd'hui et ainsi de
suite et puis comme le disait ce
policier
à l'antenne avec nous l'état a été
empêché l'état a été démantelé ces
dernières années par des idéologues qui
ne voulez pas investir qui ne voulaient
pas aidé partout où vous avez ce
sentiment d'abandon c'est parce que les
responsables politiques ont tout fait
pour que l'état n'ait plus les moyens de
remplir ses missions de service public
que ce soit l'éducation que ce soit la
protection des populations avec les
moyens dédiés de la police pour le
renseignement mais aussi la police de
quartier que ce soit les infirmiers on a
une crise sanitaire en ce moment qui est
là pour montrer les lacunes
le manque d'investissement dans
l'hôpital depuis des années tout ça est
endémique et nos chers leaders nos chers
élus on se sont cooptés pour continuer
cette politique dans je ne sais pas quel
but à part celui de faire des économies
de passer sous la barre des 3% et de
continuer de casser l'état pensant que
le privé pourra faire un meilleur boulot
mais pour les missions de service public
c'est pas le profit qui est là c'est la
question de la protection des humains
c'est grandir les humains c'est les
soigner c'est tout ce qui est oublié ces
dernières années pour l'argent c'est
l'humain et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
avec une société atomisée avec des
gamins de 18 ans qui ont de la boue dans
la tête près à décapiter des professeurs
parce qu'ils ont montré des dessins
humoristiques
c'est dingue et ça c'est une faillite
globale général pas seulement au niveau
français je pense que yahia il ya
beaucoup à dire pour notre pays mais si
la république doit répondre alors elle
doit répondre à la fois d'une manière
sécuritaire d'une manière militaire même
forte mais regardez c'est l'échec au
mali on a libéré deux cents jihadistes
pour récupérer une otage et puis
partout sur les théâtres d'opérations
regardez ce qui s'est passé en libye
c'est nicolas sarkozy président français
aujourd'hui mis en examen pour
association de malfaiteurs qui décident
de faire la guerre à la libye de
mouammar kadhafi qui aujourd'hui est un
havre du terrorisme international
donc oui nos élus nos présidents no no
no no responsables politiques ont été en
dessous de tout et il continue de l'être
alors peut-être qu'il verra un sursaut
et qu'on va arrêter de parler du rayon
communautariste au supermarché comme le
fait gérald darmanin et qu'on va parler
des vrais problèmes des moyens de quelle
va être la police de demain quelle va
être l'armée française de demain quelle
va être l'éducation nationale française
de demain
et dès aujourd'hui mettre les moyens et
renverser la vapeur faire en sorte que
toutes les superstructures de
l'administration centrale de
l'administration générale
les ars pour la santé les rectorats pour
l'éducation mais aussi la police tente
dans cette stratification qui fait que
les services n'arrive pas à se parler et
bien que tout ce management art est
d'empêcher les gens de faire leur
travail parce que tous les gens qui sont
face à élèves face à malades qui sont là
pour protéger dans la rue il demande
qu'une chose des moyens davantage de
collègues là où on en a besoin c'est à
dire là où les gens travaillent
or que disent les gens qui managent ceux
qui font les chiffres et les tableaux
excel
surtout pas c'est une question
d'organisation mais quand on a que 28
personnes qui dédié à pharos la
plateforme pour la haine en ligne qui
reçoivent plus de 160 mille plaintes par
an comment voulez vous que ces 28
personnes fassent un travail correct
ils le savent très bien ils ne sont pas
aidés et personne n'a aidé dans ce pays
donc aujourd'hui les discours c'est bien
maintenant voyons voir quels moyens vont
être mis réellement pour que la
république se défendent et qu'elle fasse
vivre ces valeurs liberté égalité et
fraternité sans qu'on ait à vivre sous
cette menace permanente de décès par
atis mme puisque c'est le mot qui est
employé par l'actuel gouvernement
alors messieurs vous restez avec nous je
vous propose tout de suite de retourner
retrouver la scène chebbi
juste devant la sorbonne il n'est pas
tout seul il est avec l'un des anciens
élèves de samuel pâtit 1 c'est bien cela
avance warbasse m
[Musique]
oui effectivement on est toujours devant
la sorbonne donc ça c'est évident et
donc la cérémonie est terminée donc le
personnes ont commencé à quitter
l'endroit sur le parvis de la sorbonne
je suis avec michael qui est un des
anciens élèves de samuel pâtit qui est
lui aussi devenu enseignant et qui a été
pour lui c'était très important
d'assister à cette cérémonie merci
beaucoup michael d'être là et de
répondre à nos questions alors première
question comment vous avez vécu cette
cérémonie
bonsoir cette cérémonie
et très émouvante ça fait mal mais on se
retrouve tous ensemble ça reste le plus
important
beaucoup de choses remontent comme ça la
surface
on a mis du tout et je me souviens que
c'était un grand fan de youtou à travers
la musique qui nous faisait aussi
découvrir l'histoire la géo politique
voilà c'était aussi ça me fait partie
animée par ses passions et qui qui s'est
servi de ses passions pour faire de la
pédagogie pour transmettre son savoir
est ce que c'était le genre de
professeurs qui aimait partager avec
vous le débat d'idées il ya ce qu'est ce
qui vous apprenez concrètement est ce
qui vous avait vraiment aidé à avoir
acquis une certaine ouverture d'esprit
est ce qui vous a donné cette vocation
devenir professeur aussi oui aussi je
pense et bien moi j'ai toujours eu pour
exemple sa manière d'organiser les
débats
c'est c'était assez impressionnant déjà
quand j'étais lycéen alors c'était 72,7
en 2000 sa débattez sur le pacs 6 or la
dépénalisation du cannabis sur la peine
de mort aussi
si on se sent plein de choses et donc il
prenait vraiment le temps
de présenter les termes du débat que
chaque élève puisse se retrouver pour
travailler et préparer ses arguments et
ensuite il y avait une confrontation est
vraiment il faisait en sorte que les
élèves ne ressortent pas simplement ce
qu'ils entendaient à la télé ce qu'ils
entendent et dans les repas de famille
mais qui développent leur propre
conscience individuelle pour ça ça a
toujours été un exemple j'ai essayé de
m'en inspirer
preuve en est dimanche dernier j'ai reçu
un mail d'une ancienne élève qui qui a
reconnu l'importance des débats qui
était content d'avoir eu des enseignants
favorisant les débats et c'est aussi ça
l'éducation
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
cérémonie a lors de cette cérémonie
je retiens la nécessité d'aider faire
bloc je devrais m'en remettre
l'éducation au sens au centre de notre
projet de société
l'éducation c'est la sphère de tous
malheureusement vous savez peut-être
aussi que aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire du mouvement pas de vague
née sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya deux ans on avait déploré le
manque de progrès de protection des
enseignants et
et la seule réponse qu'on avait eue côté
ministère c'était la loi bancaire et
l'article 1 qui qui nous a obligés à une
certaine loyauté entre guillemets et qui
nous obligeait à ne pas faire de vagues
à se taire et la question ce n'est pas
simplement de ce n'est pas simplement de
de contester mais dire que en fait moi
j'adore les discours j'adore les
références à jean jaurès
on est tous amoureux des belles lettres
des belles paroles mais à un moment il
nous faut des actes vrai semble
véritablement et là je suis désolé mais
ce gouvernement ne nous protège pas ne
nous protège pas qu'est-ce que même la
peur du couvent il nous l'a montré
donc voilà je
j'ai essayé de ne pas trop m'emballer
par les émotions mais ce qu'il nous faut
vraiment se remettre remettre
d'éducation remettre tous les personnels
de l'éducation pas seulement des
enseignants les personnels de
l'éducation au coeur d'un projet et on
en a marre de ces projets de loi qui
sont décidés par cinq gus dans un
cabinet non je suis désolé c'est nous
c'est nous tous les personnels de
l'éducation nationale qui faisont
l'éducation et qu'on se mette tous
autour d'une table pour bâtir ce projet
de société la société que nous voulons
une société unie et pas simplement d une
société d'affrontements merci beaucoup
merci pour ce témoignage d'or vous
l'avez entendu c'est un ancien élève de
samuel patyka tenait à témoigner pour
cette cérémonie nationale d'hommage à
samuel la patine c'est revenu et je vous
le rappelle qui a eu lieu ici à la
sorbonne en présence du chef de l'état
et puis de son gouvernement certaines
anciennes personnalités politiques
françois hollande était également
présent 100 élèves de différents
collèges de toute l'île de france était
présente ici la famine et de samuel
pâtit je vous rappelle qu'il a été
décoré de la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume ce fut pendant la première
partie de cette cérémonie à huis clos
entre la famille du professeur
d'histoire géographie et du chef de
l'état le cercueil rentrée devant la
cour de la sorbonne une minute de
silence a été respectée et puis beaucoup
de personnes étaient en sur place est
ici des applaudissements beaucoup
d'émotion pour cette cérémonie nationale
pour ce professeur d'histoire géographie
qui était assassiné vendredi dernier
merci beaucoup bassem on vous retrouve
un bien sûr tout à lèvres bassin chebbi
en direct devant la sorbonne rester avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons avec nos invités sur cet
hommage national qui a été rendu à
samuel pâtit cet enseignant assassiné
sauvagement vendredi dernier à conflans
sainte honorine a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
et
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de notre planète
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sap est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h30 si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france la france vient
donc de rendre hommage à samuel pâtit
tué pour avoir montré des caricatures en
classe un hommage national à paris dans
la cour de la sorbonne le lieu hautement
symbolique qui a été choisi en accord
avec la famille du défunt elle 400
personnes y ont été conviés dont une
centaine d'élèves d'établissements d'île
de france emmanuel macron a remis la
légion d'honneur à l'enseignant à titre
posthume et pour revenir sur cette
cérémonie d'hommage à samuel pâtit une
cérémonie avec des témoignages poignants
avec le discours du président nous
sommes avec nos invités alexis poulain
éditorialistes kevin bossuet professeur
d'histoire en seine saint denis est avec
nous également jean-pierre colombiès
porte parole de l'association de police
de l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants
messieurs avant de vous entendre je
propose d'écouter emmanuel macron
lorsqu'il a tenu à rappeler son soutien
au corps enseignant synonyme de devoir
républicain on l'écouté puis on réagit
ensuite nous redonnerons aux professeurs
le pouvoir de faire des républicains la
place et l'autorité qui leur reviennent
nous les formerons les considérerons
comme il se doit nous les soutiendrons
nous les protégerons autant qu'il le
faudra
dans l'école comme hors de l'école nous
aimerons la science et ses controverses
collez vous nous cultiverons la
tolérance comme vous nous chercherons à
comprendre sans relâche et à comprendre
encore davantage cela qu'on voudrait
éloigné de nous ce combat pour la
liberté et pour la raison donc vous êtes
désormais le visage parce que nous vous
le devons
parce que
nous nous le devons parce qu'en france
professeur les lumières ne s'éteignent
jamais vive la république
vive la france kevin boss fait le
professeur d'histoire que vous êtes
comment est ce que vous avez reçu ces
mots du président nous vous formerons
nous vous soutiendrons nous vous
protégerons nous vous donnerons le
pouvoir de faire des républicains
comment vous réagissez à ces mode
emmanuel macron bah écoutez c'est un
très beau discours sauf qu'il faudrait
que derrière le discours il ya des
salles vous dire concrètement nous nous
avons de grandes difficultés sur
certains territoires à faire passer une
partie du programme de la république il
ya un sondage qui est sorti récemment
qui était réalisé par l'ifop qui dit
qu'il ya notamment 40% des professeurs
qui s'autocensurent dans leur salle de
classe et on est à 50 % dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire donc que compte
faire concrètement emmanuel macron pour
qu'on puisse enseigner
concrètement ce que l'on doit enseigner
sur certaines parties du territoire il
est très compliqué d'aborder certains
sujets le professeur d'histoire
géographie ne peut plus abordé la choix
ne peut plus abordé la naissance
judaïsme ne peut plus abordé le conflit
israélo palestinien ou encore la place
de l'église au moyen-âge chance d'avoir
dans sa salle de classe des
contestations
le professeur de sciences et vie de la
terre ne peut plus abordés l'origine du
monde ou ne peut plus abordés
l'éducation à la sexualité sans devoir
faire références au coran d'ailleurs il
ya un rapport qui est sorti en 2002 qui
avait dit clairement dit qu'il y avait
une théologie isation de l'enseignement
en certains endroits parce qu'on est
obligés obligatoirement de justifier les
savoir que l'on transmet par rapport au
coran qu'est ce qu'il compte faire là
dessus j'ai entendu la députée les
républicains indigènes var qui veut
créer notamment un délit d'entravé à la
liberté d'enseignement que pense
emmanuel macron sur ce sujet et de
manière plus générale
moi en tant que professeur et mes
collègues on a eu tendance quand même
au cours de ces derniers mois d'être
véritablement méprise et il ya eu cette
réforme des retraites par exemple qu'ils
étaient tous qui a été pour nous
véritablement un coup de poignard on n'a
pas compris ce que emmanuel macron avait
contre nous il ya aussi nos salaires qui
sont strictement bas et qui sait c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas normal donc
si on veut redonner de l'autorité au
professeur si on veut faire en sorte que
les professeurs puisse incarner de
nouveau la république il faut que ces
professeurs soient respectés il faut que
ces professeurs soient honorées
par la nation à travers un salaire digne
donc voilà que confère emmanuel ma
concrètement parce que ce qui est en
train de se passer dans certaines
classes sur certains territoires
français et excessivement grave donc moi
j'en ai marre dénoncé dénoncé dénoncé
maintenant de l'action c'est ce qu'on
attend parce qu'on ne peut plus attendre
la montée de l'islamisme est telle que
si on attend encore encore un peu il
sera trop tard
alexis poulain pour former pour soutenir
pour protéger nos professeurs nos
enseignants aujourd'hui selon vous
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait mettre en place
en urgence en urgence c'est bien tout le
problème c'est incroyable de se rendre
compte de la faillite en fait de tout le
système républicain étatiques alors que
l'éducation nationale c'était le joyau
de la république sociale tout le
discours d' emmanuel macron est au futur
sur ce qu'il faudrait faire pour aider
les professeurs parce qu'ils ont
totalement lâchement étaient laissés de
côté donc en urgence rien
malheureusement pas parce que il va
falloir d'abord peut-être protéger les
professeurs les abords des écoles des
lycées des collèges et puis ensuite il
va falloir faire sortir la politique les
parents de l'école et que l'école soit
un sanctuaire républicain de la
connaissance du débat de la liberté
d'expression et que ce sens soit fini d
regardé comment fonctionnait
ces associations islamistes la moindre
porte entrouverte était le sujet pour
entrer et empêcher le débat empêcher est
imposée si possible une pensée unique ou
une censure l'école elle doit être
absence de l'absence de censure sur dans
le cadre des lois mais elle est le lieu
du débat elle est le lieu où les futurs
citoyens vont apprendre à être libre et
pas à prendre avec des petites machines
du capital donc c'est important que les
professeurs et les moyens de faire cours
correctement qu'il soit effectivement
payés correctement
regardez les salaires des professeurs
dans les pays voisins européens qui
n'ont rien à voir avec encore une fois
les salaires en france mais c'est le
même problème pour les policiers pour
les infirmières c'est le même problème
pour toute la fonction publique en
général mais c'est particulièrement
criant pour l'école parce que ils sont
en première ligne parce qu'ils sont
censés former les citoyens de demain et
ça a été rappelé par le président macron
de dire que oui c'est une bataille de la
connaissance compte
l'obscurantisme et pour ça il faut
mettre les moyens et je crois que si
immédiatement il faut faire des choses
c'est recruter ses formes est bien
entendu et c'est avoir des gestes forts
vis-à-vis des professeurs que enfin on
inverse la vapeur et que toute la
hiérarchie soutiennent les professeurs
quand ils sont attaqués quand ils sont
menacés
quand ils sont les premiers à dire
rappelez-vous pas de vagues c'est
incroyable on leur disait de se taire de
ne pas dire qu'il y avait des problèmes
voilà la réalité des rectorats chacun
couvre ses arrières au niveau
hiérarchique pour être sûr qu'il ne sera
pas celui qui prendra le boulet résultat
c'est un professeur qui se fait
décapiter parce qu'il a été laissé seul
par l'éducation nationale et par le
ministère de l'intérieur
donc ça suffit donc oui les beaux
discours je crois qu on en a entendu
suffisamment maintenant il est temps de
passer aux actes et de voir si les
rectorats peuvent changer et si on peut
recruter massivement des professeurs et
les réévaluer pour que les salaires
soient enfin à la hauteur et que les
classes ne soient plus des classes de 30
qu'on ait des classes où le débat soit
possible parce que quand vous avez
trente élèves vous faites ce que vous
pouvez pour gérer un joyeux bordel où
vous avez à la fois de l'obscurantisme
du conspirationnisme de la haine du prof
de faire tout et n'importe quoi sauf
vraiment éduqués et je crois que les
mesures qu'ils avaient sur les zones
d'éducation prioritaire l on est
renforcée elles doivent être multipliés
il faut voir aussi peut-être à étendre
ces zones prioritaires ou bien à arrêter
ces zones prioritaires à faire que toute
l'école devienne une zone prioritaire
pour que de voir cette bataille de la
connaissance soit gagné sans ça je crois
qu'on n'aura pas les armes pour pour
mener cette bataille jean pierre
colombier je m'adresse aux policiers
quand vous entendez emmanuel macron dire
il faut protéger nos professeurs
aujourd'hui au delà effectivement des
patrouilles des rondes ou ou des
postures statiques de policiers devant
les écoles est ce qu'aujourd'hui il
existe un lien entre les services de
police les écoles les chefs
d'établissements le rectorat comment ça
se passait ce qu'il y aurait quelque
chose à améliorer dans ce sens là pour
répondre à la première question est ce
qu'il y a des liens oui bien sûr qui dit
à délire il ya toujours eu des
correspondances colère mais pour tout
autre chose quoi alors là vous évoqué la
possibilité de protéger des profs
en interne scolaire et à l'extérieur
arrêtons de rêver c'est totalement
impossible on n'a ni des effectifs ni il
organisation pour ça donc c'est sert à
rien d'évoquer ce type de scénario
complètement complètement à côté de la
plaque
ce qui est navrant enfin moi je suis
désolé il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
la mois par rapport à ce discours à ce
que je viens d'entendre particulièrement
mal à l'aise je viens de voir quelqu'un
qui met un point d'honneur à prendre la
pause théâtrale à choisir des mots on
est noyé dans des mots on est noyé dans
une sémantique émotionnelle qui est un
petit mois me dérange qui moi me dérange
parce que je suis désolé comme ça a été
dit mais ça peut être dit que ce soir
sur avre à votre antenne s'était dit
depuis des années plus rien ne
fonctionne
il y à une offensive de masse contre le
service public dans ce pays
cela fait plus de vingt ans que le
service public est l'objet d' attaque
frontale que ce soit l'enseignement la
santé la police j'ai déjà dit je me
répète ça a commencé à l'ère de la
politique de la police du résultat où on
a masqué la déflation colossal du corps
de l'institution policière
on a masqué sa part une politique du
chiffre complètement et ont été
complètement trafiqués et on a fait
croire au bon peuple de france que la
police tout à coup et est efficace
qu'elle était rentable parce que on a
jeté en pâture des chiffres et des
tableaux excel et des tableaux
statistiques et à côté de ça dans le
même temps on supprimer purement et
simplement des policiers de terrain les
fameuses îlotiers eux qui étaient dans
les secteurs tout est dans les quartiers
et qui jouent un rôle fondamental
un triple rôle un triple rôle
sécuritaire parce qu'il a été il était
l'image de l'état et donc de son
autorité un rôle de coordination d'un
lien avec la citoyenneté donc un
dialogue et enfin et surtout enfin et
surtout et aussi un rôle de
renseignements que sarkozy ait détruit
les services de renseignements de à
l'époque ça tout le monde le sait tous
nous le dit maintenant c'est quelque
chose d'acquis mais ce que personne n'a
voulu voir à l'époque et c'est
catastrophique
c'est que ces petits policiers de
quartier qui étaient les invisibles de
la république quelques pas et est un
maillon essentiel dans la chaîne de
renseignement et si aujourd'hui les
services de renseignement sont à la rue
sur la ramasse haut niveau
de la remontée d'informations
d'exploitation des formations de terrain
c'est parce qu'il n'ya plus de policiers
de quartier c'est les gens du
renseignement de renseignements ou
territoriale dans les secteurs il
n'avait pas de boule de cristal s'était
pas madame irma les informations ne les
avaient pas parce qu'ils avaient vu le
la lumière céleste non c'est parce
qu'ils allaient au contact des policiers
de cartes de quartier qui leur disaient
oui mais un tel que je le connais j'ai
vu grandir je sais ce qu'il fait je sais
qu'ils fréquentent et c'est comme ça que
ça fonctionnait et c'est ce que plus ou
moins a voulu rétablir face est ce que
vous lui maintenir la police de
proximité avec beaucoup d'amateurisme
d'ailleurs dans bien des cas et beaucoup
d'hypocrisie encore une fois tous il
faut le dire c'était un site est un
marché de dupes à chaque fois et on en
crève de ça donc aujourd'hui on a un
service public dans son ensemble qui est
à l'abandon qui est à l'état de ruines
qui s'effondre donc quand j'entends
aujourd'hui des discours dur vous
protégera mais de qui se moque t'on
puisque c'est justement les mêmes qui
ont mis cette situation en place et qui
travaille qui veulent substituer aux
services d'état des services privés des
polices municipales de l'enseignement
privé par la création des nouveaux là on
favorise la multiplication des écoles
privées mais pour qui pour une classe
sociale qui de toute façon n'est pas la
même que celle des quartiers qui sont
concernés donc il ya un vrai un vrai
problème que quand vous disiez tout à
l'heure que la france est en danger oui
la france est non seulement en danger
elles mêmes en état de légitime défense
ou sous bien des aspects il faut il faut
un vrai réveil républicain mais que
cette classe politique cesse ce
nombrilisme effrayant qu'elle lui
cultive à longueur d'année à longueur de
discours et comme on vient encore de
longtemps que je suis désolé moi ce
discours de me rassure absolument pas ne
me satisfait pas
j'ai entendu deux je ne sais pas
quelqu'un qui était dans la théâtralité
de l'émotion pour qui pour quoi je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas pas pour moi
alexis vous là on vient d'entendre dans
les mots de jean pierre colombier à
cette nécessité finalement de recréer du
lien entre les policiers de quartier on
se souvient il ya quelques années
ces gendarmes se connaissaient tout le
monde aussi dans l'est dans les zones
rurales et le renseignement montée comme
ça on entend aussi parler beaucoup
d'unité nationale dans ces moments-là
lien ce lien cette unité nationale ça
doit passer par ou aujourd'hui mais ça
passe par nous tous mais ça passe
justement par ces héros invisible du
quotidien vous savez la colonne
vertébrale de la république et les
nombreuses et l'effet de tous ces
anonymes qui essayent tant bien que mal
de faire leur travail correctement les
policiers les pompiers
les soignants et les professeurs et ceux
là ont systématiquement été oubliée des
tableaux de chiffres systématiquement
été oubliés des politiques publiques
d'économie des politiques du chiffre
évidemment de dire qu'il fallait faire
comme ça de on est en vie une mascarade
en fait depuis de nombreuses années où
ce qui devrait défendre l'état là la
puissance de l'état n'ont fait que le
détricoter de l'intérieur n'ont fait que
le minée de l'intérieur pour des profits
privés pour je ne sais pas quel quels
beaux yeux de l'union européenne ou bien
de financeurs et extérieur il ya un vrai
problème de d'idéologie sur la façon
dont nous avons géré la république ou du
moins dont les élus ont géré la
république parce que ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui la font tenir au
quotidien ce dont on ne parle jamais
sauf quand il arrive un malheur
cela ils savent très bien qu'il manque
de moyens que ce soit dans les palais de
justice dans les cours de classe dans
les commissariats et dans les hôpitaux
ceux là savent très bien où est le
problème
et ceux là n'ont jamais été écoutés on
commence maintenant à les écouter
donc je me méfie des grands discours
effectivement emprunt d'emphase c'était
bien bien sûr de faire un discours ce
soir de rendre hommage à sa mère pattie
c'était important pour sa famille et
pour pour nous tous
mais au delà des discours c'est les
actes qui vont compter et les actes
souvent malheureusement depuis le début
de ce quinquennat
ils n'ont jamais suivi les discours ou
très rarement donc
reste à voir ce que va proposer le
ministre de l'intérieur
dans la lutte contre les associations et
les réseaux islamistes en france
reste à voir ce que va proposer le
président de la république et le
ministère d'éducation
dans la revue les rations des
professeurs et leur protection face à
des parents agressif face un métier de
plus en plus difficile parce qu'il en va
de l'avenir de notre modèle de société
sans toute cette cette fonction publique
qui fonctionne justement
eh bien ça ne pourra pas il n'y a pas
d'avenir pour la république française et
ce sera un délitement vers une société
du nombrilisme du chacun pour soi ou la
violence sera la règle commune
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
nombreux à vouloir rejeter la violence
et si une seule violence doit être
autorisée c'est celle de l'état pour
protéger la république et pour nous
protéger
kevin bossuet vous rejoignez les propos
entendus à l'instant par alexis poulain
bien sûr que je rejoins ses propos
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus faire dans
la demi-mesure irons nous attendons
véritablement des mesures qui soient
fermés dire à partir du moment où vous
avez une mosquée qui ne prend pas
publiquement qu'ils ne condamnent pas
pardon publiquement le meurtre de samuel
pâti cette mosquée doit être fermée à
partir du moment où vous avez une
association qui ne condamne pas
publiquement et ouvertement le meur de
samuel pâti cette association doit être
refermée
on ne peut plus faire dans la
demi-mesure et moi j'en ai marre à
chaque fois de me faire traiter
d'islamophobe de me faire traiter de
raciste ou de me faire traiter d'
extrémistes à chaque fois que je dénonce
la montée de l'islam politique aussi
bien dans les banlieues aussi bien au
sein de l'école de la république qui
continuera avec ce terrorisme
intellectuel avec cette notion
d'islamophobie en fait qu'il n'existe
pas parce que à partir du moment où on
ne fait plus la différence entre un
musulman et on ne fait plus la
différence entre un musulman radical
ceux qui payent la note c'est
véritablement tous ces musulmans qui
veulent s'intégrer et qui veulent
réussir dans l'école de la république
moi je peux vous dire que concrètement
sur le terrain je vois des familles
musulmanes ce formidable je vois des
petits musulmans formidable qui ne
veulent qu'une chose réussir dans
l'école de la république est à chaque
fois que la gauche nous accuse
d'islamophobie où nous accuse de racisme
dès qu'on dénonce les dérives de cette
religion de l'islam politique baisser
ces petits musulmans qui payent donc un
moment de
et il faut agir en républicain il faut
dénoncer tous qu'on soit de droite de
gauche tels que soit notre profession
quel que soit notre place dans la
société pour qu'on dénonce cet islam
politique il faut qu'on dénonce ces
dérives parce que c'est aujourd'hui ou
jamais c'est nous n'agissons pas
maintenant c'est les islamistes qui
gagneront parce que ce qui nous attend
derrière c'est que ce ciment grave ils
sont déjà en train de s'organiser à
travers notamment luc
l'instrumentalisation de la justice à
travers notamment l'instrumentalisation
de leur ancrage au niveau territorial et
puis il faut absolument démonte les
démanteler l'ancrage islamistes au sein
des associations de quartier au sein des
clubs de foot au sein des mosquées qui
tout c'est tous ces islamistes qui font
qu'en fait ils détruisent l'école que
l'on peut tenir au sein de l'école de la
république qui détruisent notre discours
en disant aux élèves notamment le
contraire de ce qu'on leur dit tous les
jours dans nos classes donc à un moment
il faut être ferme
il faut agir c'est eux ousseynou et
c'est maintenant que ça se joue
jean-pierre colombiès kevin bossuet
parlait des familles musulmanes
formidable qu'il rencontrait on sait
aussi que dans la police dans tous les
corps d'armées finalement il y à des
personnes de confession musulmane qui
travaillent et qui sont aussi formidable
c'est important de le dire également ce
soir
envie de vous dire heureusement si si
nous avions une énorme majorité de
musulmans en france qui étaient dans
cette dynamique mortifère
on serait on serait très très mal engagé
et le débat serait clos on reprendrait
plus je pense à quelque chose on oublie
quand même de citer un pan quand même
important du débat qu'il faut pas
exclure
on a parlé de l'oci dharmanand part de
monsieur macro on parle de plein
d'hommes politiques d'ailleurs sur
darmana et monsieur catex castex on
pourrait faire une petite parenthèse
parce qu'aujourd'hui ces personnes
politiques qui se font les ardents
défenseurs de des outils pour défendre
notre république et si malmenée faisait
partie des cabinets et les soutiens
nicolas sarkozy qui en son temps ont
déstructuré de service public petite
parenthèse que que j'ai ouverte et jouer
et que je referme rapidement pour en
parler d'ailleurs assez assez longuement
mais j'trouve ça je trouve ça c'est
assez symptomatique à ces merveilleux
c'est pudeur c'est grande pudeur
républicaine
ou c'est grand c'est grandes grandes
envolées république en soi même on a
fait partie de ceux qui a détruit et
démentent des membres et le service
public et ça monsieur castex serait bien
de s'en souvenir
ça c'est la parenthèse donc je veux
faire mais là où je veux en venir c'est
quid du ministère de la justice parce
que tout ce dont nous parlons là en ce
moment de l'éducation nationale de la
police ou de tout autre secteur tout ce
qui peut être mis en place comme
dispositif pour lutter contre
l'islamisme comme on vient de le dire ne
peut fonctionner que si c'est mis en
synergie entre plusieurs ministères
ministère de l'intérieur de l'éducation
nationale et de la justice
or je serais très curieux de savoir qui
était le point de vue vraiment la ligne
réel de monsieur dupont moretti sur ce
point parce que quand on parle par
exemple monsieur darmanin parler
d'expulsions de 231 231 personnes de
problématiques qui sont ou incarcérés ou
qui seront à être interpellé ensuite
expulsé mais j'ai pas entendu dire
fragiles ou alors je me suis j'ai loupé
une émission mais j'ai pas entendu de
commentaires de la part de monsieur
dupont moretti sur ce point parce qu'il
le sait aussi bien que les autres et
pour ceux qui ne savent pas je veux le
dire les procédures d'expulsions
d'étrangers dans ce pays en france sont
particulièrement complexes elles sont
très lourdes et ciel sont très lourdes
c'est parce qu'on a tout fait pour
qu'elle le soit on a complexifié à
outrance le schéma procédural que les
inspecteurs fait des officiers tous les
judiciaire pardon des services de police
doivent surmonter pour obtenir un
résultat mais aujourd'hui où je vais la
faire courte l'annoncent des 230 et une
expulsion
j'attends de voir si sur les 230 on en a
50 qui traversent la frontière c'est
champagne mais je n'y crois absolument
pas
donc là où je veux en venir je parle
monopolisé le temps de parole mais c'est
que tout ce dont nous parlons ne peut
fonctionner que si autour de la table
vous avez tous les partenaires de des
services et des institutions concernées
si quelqu'un dans le dans dans le schéma
joue franc tireur ou ne s'associe pas à
cette dynamique il ya cette démarche
c'est perdu d'avancé site échoué et
quand j'entends les discours monsieur
dupont moretti qui dit groupe tout de
suite qu'ils appellent au calme qui
disent on ne nous emballons pas ne nous
laissons pas aller au courant des
motions
je dis simplement que ça porte à
l'interrogation attendons de voir mais
on est loin d'être dans une unanimité
en ce qui concerne l'action sur le
terrain qui est importante qui était
indispensable
il est absolument une entente à bhl de
savoir que des professeurs sont menacés
par des gamins de 15 ans 14 ans de
savoir que la petite mila qui étaient
menacés de mort et de viol
on la change de deux lycées de collège
parce que a contrario on n'a pas le
courage de virer ce qui la menace de
crime sur on laisse proféré des menaces
de mort
donc de crimes par des individus que qui
finalement eux sont en place ne bouge
pas alors que oui pour conclure en un
mot et puis alexis poulain vous aurez le
mot de la fin
à quoi est-ce que vous serez attentif
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines alexis poulain après
cet hommage ce soir à sa maladie ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est à dire est ce que
les mesures annoncées vont effectivement
avoir lieu que ce soit la dissolution de
baraka city il ya des recours en justice
pour éviter cela la fermeture d'une
mosquée fermeture sur quelle base
derrière nous sommes dans un état de
droit donc effectivement quelles vont
être les suites légales des actions
décrites et les expulsions combien
d'expulsion sur celles qui ont été
annoncées les coups de filet dans les
réseaux islamistes y en aura-t-il
d'autres
sur quelle base voilà toutes les
questions qui vont nécessiter des
réponses et puis les réponses de long
terme pour réparer les services publics
pour réparer l'éducation nationale pour
faire que les professeurs et bien soit
enfin m dans leurs classes dans leur
école et non plus soumis à des
hiérarchies indigne idem dans l'hôpital
pour que les soignants enfin les moyens
de soigner et qu' il n'est pas à gérer
la pénurie
idem dans la police pour que enfin ce
pays fasse ce qui ce qui est nécessaire
pour protéger notre mode de vie tout
simplement
grand merci à tous les trois d'avoir
suivi avec nous cet hommage à samuel
pâtit ce soir merci ea les petits
poulains éditorialistes merci à vous
kevin bosse fait professeur d'histoire
en seine-saint-denis merci à vous jean
pierre colombiès porte parole de
l'association de police de l'union des
policiers nationaux indépendants et on
va tout de suite retrouvé sur place
notre reporter bassin chebbi pour faire
un dernier point après cet hommage
bassem bonsoir alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut retenir finalement ce soir de cet
hommage à sam elle pâtit
écoutez olivier c'est une cérémonie qui
se voulait son haleine et qui a tenu ses
promesses une cérémonie nationale en
hommage de samuel pâtit ce professeur
d'histoire géographie de conflans sainte
honorine qui a été assassinée
sauvagement ce vendredi dernier une
cérémonie qui s'est passé en deux temps
la première partie a eu lieu à huis clos
entre le chef de l'état emmanuel macron
et puis la famille du professeur
d'histoire géographie
un moment qui se voulait solennel
discret loin des caméras est loin du
public à la demande de la famille du
professeur où lui a été remis la légion
d'honneur à titre posthume
et puis la prod deuxième partie emmanuel
macron étaient dans la cour de la
sorbonne à l'entrée il est arrivé juste
après l'entrée de la dépouille du
professeur accompagnés par l orchestre
de la garde républicaine un discours a
été prononcé par son meilleur ami par
une une élève et puis par le chef de
l'état qui est revenu sur les valeurs de
la république et sur l'importance de
l'enseignement et de la liberté
d'expression beaucoup d'émotions ici sur
la place de la sorbonne où sont réunis
beaucoup de personnes pour suivre en
direct avec un écran qui a été mis en
place sur la place beaucoup de personnes
beaucoup d'émotion on a pu échanger avec
eux des discours énormément de personnes
du gouvernement étaient présentés puis
d'anciens politiques notamment françois
hollande d'anciens présidents de la
république étaient présents le corps de
samuel aphatie a quitté à la sorbonne à
l'issue d'une minute de silence qui a
succédé au discours et emmanuel macron
accompagné par la garde républicaine
hors caisse de la garde républicaine
mitt romney qui se voulait sur la ligne
s'est remis importante pour cet hommage
au professeur d'histoire géographie qui
a été assassiné vendredi dernier merci
beaucoup
bassem pour toutes ces précisions bassem
chebi en direct depuis la sorbonne
rester avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous partions aux
états unis où nous retrouverons
stéphanie de murs eu notre envoyé
spécial à washington qui suivra pour
nous la campagne présidentielle depuis
washington et puis retour en france
le premier ministre jean castex tiendra
une conférence de presse ce jeudi sur la
situation sanitaire a tout de suite sur
rt france
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
j'avais encore que sundance
c'est un conte pour les gens qui ne
peuvent pas être exposé au soleil ils me
disent c'est donc un camp pour les
vampires
je crois que c'est comme un centre
d'hébergement pour eux n'ont pas à
parler de tout ce qu'ils traversent
parce que nous comprenons tous notre
fille katie a été diagnostiqué d'une
maladie très rare d'hypersensibilité au
soleil si j'ai un coup de soleil je
guéris elle elle ne guérit pas elles ont
aussi des problèmes moteurs des
problèmes d'élocution et d'audition
le volume du cerveau diminue nettement
en deçà le crâne grandi et le cerveau
rapetisse il est impossible de décrire
cette douleur c'est comme une brûlure
chimiques très très grave
la douleur face dans la peau des muscles
jusqu'aux os c'est impossible à soulager
parfois nous sommes mis à l'épreuve non
pour montrer nos faiblesses mais pour
découvrir nos forces
dans les bancs où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas l'autre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause d un politique et sont en
train de manipuler l'armée on sait très
bien pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus
c'est pas s'ils savent que c'est leur
fin ils se préparent le seul langage
qu'ils connaissaient la violence il ne
va pas trop violent mais on va rester
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 21 octobre 2020 j - 13 et
dernière ligne droite dans la campagne
présidentielle américaine premier
meeting de barack obama ce soir dans
l'attaqué de pennsylvanie pour apporter
son soutien à dubaï donnent le candidat
démocrate a choisi de rester dans son
domaine du de la war pour préparer
l'ultime débat contre donald trump
il aura lieu demain soir dans le
tennessee le locataire de la maison
blanche continue lui de sillonner le
pays pour rattraper son retard dans les
sondages et tous les jours dans cette
émission nous retrouverons stéphanie de
murs eu notre envoyé spécial à
washington elle suivra pour nous cette
campagne en france c'est jean castex qui
tiendra ce jeudi une conférence de
presse sur le coronavirus et un certain
nombre de départements basculeront en
alerte maximale face à la progression de
l'épidémie a indiqué aujourd'hui le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent elle l'exécutif veut également
prolongé l'état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 16 février le premier ministre
reprend la main alors que le
gouvernement avertit aller couvre-feu
n'auront pas d'effet avant deux à trois
semaines
[Musique]
marché conclu pour un avenir plus vert
les ministres de l'union européenne se
sont mis d'accord ce mercredi sur une
réforme de la politique agricole commune
elle marque l'entrée de règles
environnementales plus contraignantes et
la mise en place d éco régime soit un
système de primes versées aux
agriculteurs qui soutiennent des
programmes environnementaux exigeant
haut karabagh le conflit dans l'impasse
le premier ministre arménien appelle les
arméniens à se porter volontaires au
front et exclut toute solution
diplomatique dans le même temps après
l'échec de deux trêves les ministres
arménien et azerbaïdjanais des affaires
étrangères sont en russie pour des
consultations diplomatiques séparés avec
moscou avant des entretiens séparés ce
vendredi à washington avec le chef de la
diplomatie américaine mike pompey
[Musique]
direction les états unis tout de suite
où la campagne présidentielle bat son
plein à 13 jours de l'élection nous
retrouvons tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial stéphanie de mu rue pour
commenter la lutte acharnée à laquelle
se livrent donald trump et joe biden
[Musique]
bonjour stéphanie très heureux de vous
retrouver depuis washington
bonsoir olivier alors à moins de deux
semaines du jour j la con la campagne
s'intensifie et tous les coups bas sont
permis on dirait ah oui c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
olivier c'est une campagne très violente
évidemment l'enjeu est de taille
on s'en doute tous les camps en prennent
pour leur grade le new york times 1
notamment pas connu vraiment pour être
un journal impartiale classé à gauche
accuse donald trump a accusé donald
trump fière d'avoir un compte en chine
un compte qu'il aurait eue avant même
d'être élu mais qu'ils n'auraient
finalement jamais fermé il est donc
accusé d'avoir tenté de commercer avec
de grandes entreprises chinoises
chinoise sous contrôle d'état et ce
pendant tout son mandat d accusation
donc relayé à part ce journal de gauche
mais évidemment donald trump est pas le
seul à recevoir des coups à son
adversaire
joe biden c'est la même chose et les
coûts sont distribués par le président
américain lui-même ainsi que onze
députés républicains qui demandent au
procureur général une enquête poussée
sur une affaire de corruption qui
toucherait à joe biden en clair un
potentiel scandale explosif de trafic
d'influencé et de corruption dans le
cadre d'une affaire qui touche son fils
center pour la petite histoire
d'ailleurs le président à la commission
du renseignement de la chambre des
représentants démocrates
adam schiff avait d'ailleurs tenté
d'attribuer à la russie la diffusion de
cette responsabilité en anglais faire
by donne mais le directeur du
renseignement américains national a dit
qu'il ne croyait pas du tout à cette
implication de la russie je referme
cette parenthèse écouter ce que dit
donald trump de cette affaire justement
joe biden interrogé par joe biden et par
sa colistière sur un tout autre sujet la
fracturation hydraulique écouter ce
qu'ils renault is le président américain
est-ce qu'on ne montre pas c'est la
version la plus récente
oui on aura des fracturations
hydrauliques les défis qu'il ne faut
rien à ce sujet il ne lui en parle même
pas et en ce moment il a de plus gros
problème que la facturation hydraulique
je pense vous savez ce que c'est c'est
le diable d'ordinateurs portables ce
diable d'ordinateurs portables et ce
fameux ordinateur portable il serait
actuellement dans les mains du fbi
haillan c'est ce qu'affirment plusieurs
sources à fox news
une chose est certaine on entend très
peu la défense de joe biden sur ce point
que joe biden a décidé d'aller s'isoler
dans son domaine du delaware pour
préparer le grand débat un final qui
aura lieu demain à nashville dans le
tennessee et donc aucun mot vraiment
officiel pour le moment de la part du
candidat démocrate sur cette affaire ce
qui a encore une fois va lui l'ironie
est il et sarcasmes de donald trump
il a pris une pause de cinq jours je
veux dire que ce gars tout ce qu'il fait
c'est resté chez lui
vous savez pourquoi vous savez pourquoi
parce que tu ne peux pas répondre en
question maintenant tu ne peux répondre
à aucune question
et dans cette guerre acharnée stéphanie
les médias américains ne semblent pas
vraiment impartiaux
dans c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
olivier c'est un petit peu la campagne
dans la banque campagne c'est vrai que
les médias américains contrairement
peut-être aux médias voilà français qui
le font peut-être d'une manière un petit
peu plus feutrée affiche une forme voilà
de décomplexer à afficher leur
préférence
que l'on soit finalement du côté de
trump ou du côté de joe biden il serait
de mauvaise foi d'affirmer que les
médias sont neutres
dans cette affaire les médias
traditionnels américains affichent un
soutien ses indéfectibles à joe biden
alors qu'il passe plutôt leur temps avec
une campagne agressif à l'encontre de
donald trump seule la chaîne classé à
droite fox news tentant de parler de
cette affaire où joe biden pour gêner
certainement le candidat démocrate alors
qu'une chaîne par exemple on le voit
quand on allume la télé ici aux etats
unis comme cnn préfère parler de
l'agenda des candidats du bilan plutôt
médiocre à leur goût de donald trump est
également beaucoup de la crise du
coronavirus qui prend une grande partie
de la place sur la chaîne cnn écoutez
justement à ce propos encore une fois
les sarcasmes décidément de donald trump
la pandémie les gens commencent en avoir
marre de la pandémie non moi j'en ai
marre sur cnn il ne parle que de ça qu
witko vide pour des bouillies qu'ovide
qu'ovide ils essaient de dissuader tout
le monde de voter les gens ne sont pas
du cnn quel idiot ne sont pas dus il ne
parle que de ça
alors stéphanie quel est le programme du
jour pour les deux candidats alors on
l'a dit un olivier pour joe biden et
bien ce sera studio studio un week end
passé avant plutôt une semaine à
quelques jours parce que ça fait depuis
lundi qu'il prépare ce fameux débat
final
évidemment beaucoup d'enjeux autour de
ce débat qui se passera demain à
nashville dans le tennessee
la stratégie du candidat c'est sans
doute se montrer le moins possible
peut-être pour éviter parfois dégâts fin
dont on l'accuse souvent pas
d'événements publics donc au programme
mais il pourra compter sur une présence
un soutien de taille celui de l'ancien
président dont il était d'ailleurs le
vice président barack obama qui s'était
attendu ce soir en pennsylvanie pour son
premier meeting de soutien en faveur de
joe biden écouter barack obama qui parle
du fond de la campagne celui tout le
monde
l'une des choses les plus inspirantes de
cette année a été de voir autant de
jeunes américains plaint d' enthousiasme
marché et se battre pour des changements
le vote seule ne permet pas d'y parvenir
mais on n'arrive à rien sans passer par
le vote
votre vote ne fait pas que compte et ils
comptent plus que jamais pour changer la
donne sur les thèmes qui nous importe
joe biden a besoin de vos voix et joe
biden qui pourra donc également compter
sur sa colistière kamala harris qui elle
participera ce soir à deux événements en
caroline du nord pour ainsi d inciter au
vote anticipé il faut savoir que 40
millions à presque 40 millions
d'américains ont déjà voté de manière
anticipée
c'est un record c'est précisément en
caroline du nord que donald trump
donnera ce soir un nouveau meeting
donald trump qui ne cesse de sillonner 1
les etats unis sans doute vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure pour rattraper un
retard assez considérable dans les
sondages une stratégie qui avait en tous
les cas payé en 2016 et qui se
reproduira espère donald trump
merci beaucoup stéphanie et
on se retrouve bien évidemment demain
pour continuer à suivre avec vous
l'élection présidentielle américaine
[Musique]
retour en france savez à présent edouard
philippe devant les députés pour rendre
compte de sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire l'ex premier ministre a été
auditionné cet après-midi par la
commission denquête à l'assemblée
nationale le point avec notre reporter
katia technique durant près de trois
heures de cette audition edouard
philippe a nié tout retard pris dans la
gestion de la pandémie expliquant s'être
réuni avec les équipes dès les premiers
frémissements
et puis il a expliqué qu'il ne disposait
pas d'un plan adapté vu qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'une épidémie connu et
puis qu'il avait également été freiné
dans ses décisions
à cause de l'écart entre les règles
étatiques et la décentralisation extrême
qu'il était compliqué de piloter toutes
les strates décisionnaire concernant la
pénurie de masques et bien les documents
ne lui sont pas parvenus et c'est normal
explique-t-il
et puis les personnes âgées on n'est pas
de contrainte de rester dans
l'établissement plutôt que d'aller à
l'hôpital est bien pour lui si elle y
était venue et bien ça aurait pu
surcharger les capacités d'occupation de
l'hôpital et c'est bien tout problème
puisque le gouvernement avait dit que
l'hôpital avait tenu évidemment sont les
personnes âgées c'est plus simple
concernant l'ue l'inutilité du port du
masque comme souvent edouard philippe à
blâmer les incertitudes scientifiques
c'était sa ligne de défense vous propose
de l'écouter s'il s'agit d'intégrer des
éléments qui sont eux très strictement
médico sanitaires alors c'est plus
compliqué pour une raison simple c'est
que s'agissant des informations
médicales s'agissant de la
caractérisation de ce qu'était ce virus
avant on ne sait pas tout dès le début
d'ailleurs je suis incapable de dire si
on sait tous aujourd'hui je pense que tu
as n'est pas le cas mais on a longtemps
on s'est longtemps posé beaucoup de
questions sur le fonctionnement non pas
la réalité du tout elle a été prise en
compte très très tôt et sur le
fonctionnement de ce virus chose
importante le premier ministre a
justifié la tenue à des municipales
expliquant qu'il n'y avait pas de
consensus politique ou scientifique pour
les ajournés
et le tout noyé dans un langage
technocratique voilà ce qui ne peut
retenir de cette audition qui ne permet
pas vraiment de pointer les
responsabilités de tel ou tel
face à l'évolution de l'épidémie le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand se dit lui favorable à
un report des élections départementales
et régionales prévues en mars 2021
écouter quand on me demande mon avis je
dis une chose simple
on avait dit pour les municipales
puisqu'on peut aller acheter sa baguette
de pain on peut donc aller voter certes
sauf qu'une élection ce n'est pas que le
jour du scrutin une élection c'est une
campagne électorale ont fait du porte à
porte on fait des réunions publiques ont
fait des débats on essaye de convaincre
et tout cela est impossible aujourd'hui
et le sera très vraisemblablement dans
les mois qui viennent et la situation
sanitaire dans le pays à présent un
point sur les derniers chiffres santé
publique france dénombre 26 1676
nouvelles contaminations au co vie dans
24 heures 166 personnes sont décédées à
l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 13,7 pour cent
au total le nombre de morts s'élève à 34
milles 48 et pour en parler nous sommes
avec stéphane caillet médecins
infectiologues au chru de strasbourg
stéphane caillet merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors au vu des
chiffres la situation sanitaire
un mérite t'elle un nouveau tour de vis
selon vous un certain nombre de
départements vont passer en alerte
maximale dès demain à priori a indiqué
le porte parole du gouvernement
on constate depuis une petite semaine
qu'il y a en effet une augmentation du
nombre de cas mais je ne compte pas
tellement les cas de l'écart positif je
compte plutôt les cas de maladie parce
que ce sont ceux là qui ont vraiment du
sens sur le plan de l'épidémiologie et
les données que nous avons à disposition
sont essentiellement le nombre quotidien
de nouvelles hospitalisations qui montre
une augmentation en effet depuis
quelques jours et le nombre quotidien de
nouvelle admission en réanimation
effectivement depuis quelques jours
on voit une reprise de l'épidémie mais
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'explosion à
laquelle nous avons assisté fin mars
début avril
alors faut-il resserrer la vis je pense
que il serait déjà bien de réussir à
faire appliquer très correctement les
mesures qui sont édictées avant d'en
ajouter d'autres c'est les gestes
barrières par exemple alors les gestes
barrière c'est surtout le masque
j'entendais à l'instant l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe de discuter du
mas le masque reste la première mesure
de prévention
malgré tout ce que l'on dit on dit une
chose et son contraire
c'est un virus respiratoires
essentiellement respiratoires et le
masque reste la principale mesure de
prévention
à condition qu'il soit bien porté et là
encore il ya de nombreuses insuffisances
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut répéter parce que c'est la vérité
on a l'impression que beaucoup de gens
portent leur masque dès l'instant où ils
sont en public et ils savent qu'ils sont
observés
et puis dès l'instant où on se retrouve
en petit comité entre soi et bien le
masque a tendance à tomber et tout est
là si c'est ça le problème et on a on a
dénoncé les soirées les soirées entre
adolescents adultes ou jeunes et on sait
très bien que il ya une concentration
humaine dans des locaux exigus sans
ventilation et à ce moment là il n'y a
plus de tous deux masques cuirassé est
justement vous parlez
de ces fêtes des jeunes le couvre feu
est-ce que c'est suffisant selon vous
tel qu'il est mise en place aujourd'hui
c'est à dire à partir de 21h est-ce que
19 heures ce serait mieux quel est votre
regard sur ce couvre-feu à mon avis 21h
c'est suffisant 19h serait vraiment
invivable ça consisterait à mettre tout
les laisse ou les soirées à l'arrêt
c'est 21h c'est déjà bien mais est ce
que on a des moyens de les faire
respecter ce couvre-feu
tout à l'heure il n'est pas suffisamment
respecté aujourd'hui la 2d vous d'après
ce que vous observez nous n'avons
honnêtement nous n'avons pas les moyens
de le faire respecter suffisamment et je
sais très bien par ouï dire parce que
des caves ont été rapportées qui vient
encore beaucoup d'entorses à au respect
du couvre-feu est bon et je reviens
toujours à ccc soirée parce qu'il ya eu
plusieurs travaux à ce sujet ces soirées
notre âme a notamment entre étudiants où
il n'y a pas du tout dû à ce qu il n'y a
pas du tout le port de masques alors
comment ça arrange t-il pour éviter de
se retrouver dans la rue et d'éviter
d'être surpris je ne sais pas mais le
couvre-feu manifestement ne suffit pas
tout à fait bon mais il est encore un
petit peu tôt il faut attendre encore
quelques jours mais atteint que si d'ici
la fin de la semaine
la l'augmentation du nombre d'admissions
en réanimation et d'hospitalisation
continue à elle être confirmée là il
faudra quand même réfléchir il ya une
adaptation des mesures est juste
peut-être une adaptation des méthodes de
contrôle
justement à strasbourg quelle est la
situation est ce qu'on se rapproche du
seuil d alerte
la situation à strasbourg heureusement
tout se passe bien on est dans une zone
d'assez faible circulation du virus le
secteur hospitalier est très loin d'être
saturé et de la situation on peut dire
que ledit à strasbourg et contrôlée elle
n'a rien à voir avec ce qui se passe par
exemple en ile de france et vous vous
étiez
comment devez-vous faire comment elles
sont prêtes à faire face à une seconde
vague massive comment ça se passe
massive peut être pas mais une
augmentation franche du nombre
d'hospitalisations et du nombre
d'admissions en réanimation
oui certainement merci beaucoup
stéphane caillet d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecins infectiologues au chru de
strasbourg merci à vous la france a donc
rendu hommage ce soir à samuel pâtit le
professeur d'histoire-géographie tué
pour avoir montré des caricatures en
classe un hommage national à paris dans
la cour d'honneur de la sorbonne une
cérémonie présidée par emmanuel macron
il a remis la légion d'honneur à
l'enseignant à titre posthume
écoutez le chef de l'état il est revenu
sur le choix hautement symbolique de la
sorbonne ce soir
je veux parler de votre fils je veux
parler de votre frère
de votre oncle
de celui que vous avez aimé de ton père
ce soir je veux parler de votre collègue
de votre professeur tomber parce qu'il
avait fait le choix d'enseignés
[Musique]
assassiné parce qu'il avait décidé
d'apprendre à ses élèves à devenir
citoyens à prendre les devoirs pour les
remplir à prendre les libertés pour les
exercer ce soir
je veux vous parler
de samuel pâtit samuel pâtit aimer les
livres le savoir plus que tout son
appartement était une bibliothèque c'est
plus beau cadeau des livres pour
apprendre
il aimait les livres pour transmettre à
ses élèves comme à ses proches
la passion de la connaissance le goût de
la liberté
après avoir étudié l'histoire à lyon et
avoir envisagé devenir chercheur il
avait emprunté la voie tracée par vous
séparant instituteur et directeur
d'école à moulins en devenant chercheurs
en pédagogie comme il aimait à se
définir en devenant professeur aussi
ne pouvait-on trouver meilleur endroit
que la sorbonne notre lieu de savoir
universel depuis + de vie siècle le lieu
de l'humanisme pour que la nation puisse
lui rendre cet hommage le lieu hautement
symbolique de la cour de la sorbonne
dont qui a été choisi en accord avec la
famille du défunt à 400 personnes ont
été conviées à cette cérémonie pleine
d'émotion parmi ses invités une centaine
d'élèves d'établissements d'île de
france
retour sur le déroulé de cette soirée
avec notre reporter basse m shelly c'est
ici à la sorbonne qui a eu lieu
l'hommage à samuel pâtit ce professeur
d'histoire géographie de conflans sainte
honorine qui a été assassinée
sauvagement vendredi dernier un hommage
national ici à la sorbonne en présence
de 200 invités du président de la
république et de son gouvernement
beaucoup de personnalités d'anciens
politiques comme françois hollande
ancien président de la république
étaient présents également beaucoup
d'élèves 100 élèves de différentes
écoles et collèges de la région ile de
france l'orchestré national de la de la
garde républicaine a accompagné l'entrée
de la dépouille de samuel pâti des
prises de parole aussi des discours du
chef de l'état
une cérémonie qui s'est passé en deux
temps la première partie était à huis
clos entre la famille de samuel paty et
le chef de l'état ils ont pu se
recueillir et plus le chef de l'état a
remis la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume à ce professeur avant de gagner
de regagner pardon la cour de la
sorbonne pour adresser un message et un
discours solennel le chef de l'état est
revenu sur les valeurs de la république
et l'importance de l'enseignement et de
la liberté est d'expression énormément
de personnes étaient réunies ici sur la
place de la sorbonne pour assister à
cette cérémonie qui a été retransmise en
direct ici la cérémonie a pu être suivie
énormément de prise de parole et puis la
dépouille de samuel patty a quitté la
cour de la sorbonne accompagnés par
l'orchestré de la garde républicaine
une cérémonie qui se voulait sonae et
qui a tenu ses promesses pour cet
hommage national pour ce professeur
d'histoire géographie samuel pâtit
professeur à conflans sainte honorine
assassiné sauvagement vendredi dernier
à rester avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
politique agricole commune les ministres
de l'union européenne se sont mis
d'accord ce mercredi sur une réforme
résolument verte puis nous parlerons du
haut karabagh les ministres arménien et
azerbaïdjanais des affaires étrangères
sont en russie pour des consultations
diplomatiques séparés avec moscou à
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la maison
hu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense ont gommé tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs tenu de la situation s'est
aggravée avec le début d' attaques
contre la frégate courbet 10 juillet les
mots n'assure contre la grèce et la
présence de dieu à dist syriens venus
d'idlib haut karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire
mais compte tenu des divergences avec l
europe pourront nous le faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu bas voilà c'est fini pour moi
est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française un accord trouvé pour les 27
pays de l'union européenne sur la
réforme de la politique agricole la
nouvelle est tombée aujourd'hui
ainsi l'union européenne se félicite de
cette nouvelle orientation à les ong la
critique en mettant en avant les
contraintes auxquelles les exploitants
devront faire face
autre détail qui divise dans ce nouvel
accord dont le montant de
l'investissement dégagé par l'ua qui
représente plus d'un tiers de son budget
total à les détails avec médiers ce qui
fit la politique agricole commune
c'est l'une des discussions qui étaient
au coeur des échanges de l'union
européenne ces derniers jours au
luxembourg un accord sur la réforme de
cette politique a été trouvé par les 27
ministres européens de l'agriculture
cette nouvelle orientation se
matérialise par des normes strictes en
matière de protection de l'environnement
que les agriculteurs doivent respecter
une pac plus verte selon le ministère
français de l'agriculture
après de nombreuses heures de
négociations nous avons obtenu un accord
qui correspond aux attentes fortes de la
france des mesures environnementales
obligatoire pour tous les états membres
permettant d'éviter toute distorsion de
concurrence c'est donc une pac plus
verte mais surtout plus juste
c'était une demande forte de la france
un projet qui comprend un investissement
de 387 milliards d'euros d' aide aux
agriculteurs et qui doit entrer en
vigueur dès janvier 2023 pour une
période de sept ans il s'agit du premier
secteur de dépense de lieux
du côté européen on met également en
avant une réussite
après de longues discussions il y à
quelques heures à peine nous avions des
opinions très divergentes
il s'agit d'une bonne nouvelle pour nos
agriculteurs qui ont besoin d'une
sécurité de planification pour les
prochaines années beaucoup d'argent en
jeu et des règles environnementales plus
contraignantes pour les exploitations
une orientation politique qui est loin
de faire l'unanimité
la pac qu'on nous propose pour 2023 ne
propose rien de nouveau elle est dans la
continuation des précédentes
elle va donc continuer à provoquer des
désastres mais elle correspond aux
attentes des grands lobbys qui entoure
et profite des agriculteurs
le lobby agro chimique et le lobby
agroalimentaire qui sont les principaux
bénéficiaires d'une agriculture
productiviste
elle représente plus d'un tiers du
budget total de l'union européenne s'est
énormément d'argent public
donc cela nous concerne toutes et tous
pour autant rien n'est encore gagné
ce nouveau plan doit être voté par les
eurodéputés ce vendredi un vote final
qui sera suivie d'une négociation entre
le parlement la commission et les états
membres dans l'objectif d'un accord de
concerts d'ici début des années 2000 21
des discussions et des échanges qui
s'annonce mouvementée et pour en parler
nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
claude blanchemaison merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
pac
certes elle encore à quelque chose
aujourd'hui la pac c'est un élément tout
à fait stratégique à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
d'ailleurs le général de gaulle ne s'y
était pas trompé puisque en 1965 il
avait fait la politique de la chaise
vide c'est à dire que la france allait
pas siéger dans les instances de
décision de l'union européenne pour
obliger nos cinq partenaires de l'époque
à passer à une véritable politique
agricole commune intégrée donc l'origine
et est effectivement historique alors
que permettait sûr sur le plan
stratégique cette politique agricole
commune intégrée et bien elle a permis
tout simplement de rendre l'union
européenne
auto suffisante sur le plan
agroalimentaire et non seulement auto
suffisante mais avec une capacité
d'exportation très importante puisque
l'union européenne exporte beaucoup et
la france
parmi ses états membres est l'un de ceux
qui exportent plus en matière
agroalimentaire
donc c'est le rôle que joue la politique
agricole commune seule politique
sectorielle véritablement intégré à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et qui
a joué plusieurs rôles naturellement ce
rôle aujourd'hui évoluer doit évoluer
puisque l'objectif de l'autosuffisance
alimentaire de la modernisation de
l'agriculture a été a été le très
largement atteint et tout
cela ne coûte il pas trop cher
finalement le cadre financier a été fixé
en juillet par les chefs d'état de
gouvernement et vous avez un chiffre
tout à l'heure 386 milliards d'euros
pour 7 en 2021 et 2027 et ceci
représente à peu près la même somme que
pour les sept années précédentes la même
somme puisque si l'on tient compte de la
sortie du royaume-uni qui ne participe
plus à la politique agricole commune et
qui va avoir à monter des dispositifs d
aide à ces agriculteurs parce que tous
les pays ont des dispositifs à leurs
agriculteurs et bien le royaume-uni est
en partie ce qu'il touchait va se
répartir entre les autres vêtements et
les principaux bénéficiaires sont
premièrement la france deuxièmement
l'allemagne
troisièmement l'espagne quatrièmement
l'italie est d'ailleurs le royaume uni
entre parenthèses était le sixième
bénéficier donc ça ne va faire une
économie de ce côté et par conséquent un
petit bonus à répartir alors la france
là dessus touche donc une la part du
lion en réalité depuis le début parce
qu'elle a su s'adapter aux différentes
évolutions de la politique agricole
commune ce n'est pas la première réforme
de la pac ait eu beaucoup de réformes de
la pac
d'abord pour absorber les différents
levergies semant un choc considérable
lorsque l'espagne est entrée dans
l'union européenne puisque c'était un
grand producteur agricole et à des chocs
aussi considérable lorsque la pologne et
la hongrie qui bénéficie très largement
des soutiens de la potée agricole
commune sont entrés la pologne et la
hongrie
comme les autres pays d'ailleurs
tiennent beaucoup à cette politique
agricole commune
parce que elle est un élément essentiel
du soutien au revenu de leurs
agriculteurs mais progressivement
évidemment on a évolué vers une
politique agricole commune qui aide et
une aide à la production est pas à
l'entreprise et par conséquent les
grandes entreprises est évidemment
du coup touche davantage que les petites
entreprises qui peut être en auraient le
plus besoin
et est ce que la réforme de la pac peut
porter préjudice aux intérêts des
agriculteurs français
alors effectivement vous avez dit que
tout à l'heure que les ong et les verts
n'étaient pas contents et considère que
ce qui a été décidé en matière de
réformes qui d'ailleurs ne s'appliquera
que à partir du 1er janvier 2023 n'était
pas suffisant il faut noter quand même
que l à fait né sera le grand syndicat
agricole est satisfait était satisfait
déjà de la proposition de la commission
est satisfait du compromis qui est
intervenu cette nuit à luxembourg à la
main sur la sphère fnsea représente
plutôt les grandes entreprises
productives et rentables et peut-être
moins les petites entreprises qui sont
dans la difficulté
d'ailleurs on note que d'autres
syndicats agricoles ont critiqué le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas un plafond dead par
entreprises ont critiqué aussi le fait
qu' il n'y ait pas suffisamment de
mesures en faveur de l'environnement et
ont bien sûr compte sur le parlement
européen qui prendra sa décision
vendredi
pour qu'il y à un deuxième tour dans
cette négociation pour tenir compte de
l'avis du parlement européen en tout
état de cause tout ceci est assez limité
puisque le budget de l'union européenne
c'est 1% du pnb de l'union européenne en
gros et puisque on a dit tout à l'heure
que l'agriculture ça représentait la
politique révèle commune un peu plus
d'un tiers de ce budget
ça veut dire qu'avec en gros 0 35 % du
pnb de l'union européenne
on a beau on assure son autosuffisance
alimentaire et ses capacités
d'exportation mais y encore beaucoup à
faire en matière de qualité en matière
de protection de la nature en matière
d'environnement
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre éclairage rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales
et dans le reste de l'actualité nord
stream ii les états unis étendent leurs
sanctions concernant ce projet
gaz de l'ue contre la russie et
l'allemagne des sanctions qui visent
désormais toute personne ou entreprise
qui facilite la fourniture des navires
pose en est les tuyaux mais aussi celle
responsable de la maintenance washington
farouchement opposé à ce projet gazier
se dit prêt à utiliser une vaste palette
de sanctions pour y mettre fin à écouter
nous continuons d'appeler la russie a
cessé d'utiliser ses ressources
énergétiques à des fins coercitives la
russie utilise ses pipelines
d'exportation d'énergie pour créer des
dépendances nationale et régionale
vis-à-vis des approvisionnements
énergétiques russes en tirant parti de
ses dépendances pour étendre son
influence politique économique et
militaire a fait bien la sécurité
européenne et sapé la sécurité nationale
américaine et les intérêts de politique
étrangère des états unis et le point sur
ce dossier tout de suite avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine cléroux
ce ne sont plus seulement les personnes
physiques ou morales impliquées dans la
pose du gazoduc en elle-même être visées
par les sanctions mais aussi dorénavant
les sociétés qui assiste les navires
dans leurs opérations et celles chargées
de la maintenance
l'objectif des autorités américaines est
donc clair empêcher par tous les moyens
que notre en service le gazoduc nord
stream 2 par contre sur un tout autre
sujet celui de la prolongation du traité
new start de limitation des armes
stratégiques nucléaires
on observe une amélioration un début de
convergence des points de vue entre
moscou et washington
mais pour le kremlin ces deux dossiers
ne sont pas liés cela peut difficilement
être considérée comme deux choses
interdépendantes
d'une manière générale il s'agit d'une
politique plutôt hostile et destructrice
consistant à introduire constamment
diverses restrictions contre nous contre
nos acteurs économiques contre notre
économie malheureusement cela fait déjà
partie intégrante de cette concurrence
ouvertement déloyale de cette
concurrence de racket de la part de
washington
malheureusement cette politique
destructrice poursuit depuis plusieurs
années et bien entendu elle nuit à nos
relations bilatérales
il paraît existait en effet et c'est une
bonne nouvelle une volonté commune de
prolonger d'un an le dernier grand
traité de limitation des armements
stratégiques qui lit encore la russie
les etats unis le temps de poursuivre
les consultations sur l'avenir de ce
type d'armement mais comme l'a souligné
dimitri peskov
l'attitude et surtout les mesures
adoptées par washington sur d'autres
sujets comme celui de nord stream ii par
exemple ne font rien pour arranger les
relations entre les deux pays au nigeria
à présent le siège de la station de
télévision privée tv c'est connu pour
ses liens avec un éminent politicien
nigérian a été incendié à lagos un
événement qui arrivent au lendemain de
la répression sanglante d'une
manifestation pacifique selon amnesty
international au moins 12 personnes ont
été tuées mardi soir par l'armée et la
police nigériane une répression
condamnée par l'union européenne le
point avec leïla sarraf leur pays sonné
par les violences il manifeste
les nigérians vivant à londres devant
l'ambassade du nigeria sont solidaires
de ceux au pays qui se mobilisent contre
le pouvoir
à lagos toute action est bonne à prendre
comme celle de bloquer l'aéroport on
bloque l'aéroport international car
depuis que je suis dans le ventre de ma
mère
j'entends que le nigeria s'améliore mais
jusqu'à présent on ne fait que souffrir
alors nous voulons nous battre pour nos
droits pour qu'ils sachent que nous
ressentons de la douleur nous faisons ce
blocage pour essayer de leur dire que ça
suffit
une contestation qui a débuté il ya deux
semaines sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'appel du mouvement et ns sas qui
milite contre les violences policières
particulièrement visés la brigade
spéciale de répression des vols une
mobilisation inédite à laquelle de
nombreux artistes ont contribué cela
n'était jamais arrivé et je suis fier de
notre génération wii fier et je tiens
aussi à vous dire que ce gouvernement
s'est attaqué à la mauvaise et
génération il est l'égal de militer pour
nos droits tant que ça reste pacifique
et nous voilà en train de protester
pacifiquement nous n'avons pas de chef
une chose est sûre les jeunes les masses
voulait que nous autres les célébrités
prenions la parole et nous voilà
et je reste ici jusqu'à demain je ne
vais nulle part est-ce que je vais
rentrer à la maison
non en dépit du couvre feu total imposé
mardi par les autorités
le siège d'une station de télévision
connu pour ses liens avec le
gouvernement a été incendiée ce mercredi
tout comme des commerces dans de
nombreuses villes du pays
de la colère en réponse aux mardis
cinglant et à la répression des forces
de l'ordre sur plus de mille
manifestants
nous demandons au gouvernement de venir
à notre secours de venir nous aider pour
que nous puissions nous reposer ça a
commencé en brûlant des voitures
avant que vous ne vous en rendiez compte
ils ont aussi brûlé quelques magasins et
ils ont tué une dizaine de personnes
hier et aujourd'hui encore ils ont tué
jusqu'à trois ou quatre personnes
la situation est donc incontrôlable nous
demandons au gouvernement de nous venir
en aide
si l'armée nigériane a d'ores et déjà
nié être à l'origine de la fusillade de
mardi
la réaction du président mohamadou
buhari en fonction depuis 2015 ce fait
elle toujours attendre en guinée la peur
de la guerre civile après la mort d'au
moins neuf personnes dont un policier
dans des heurts entre forces de l'ordre
et partisans de l'opposition ce mercredi
à conakry à des violences trois jours
après les élections présidentielles
organisées à l'issue de plusieurs mois
de contestation meurtrières dans ce pays
de l'afrique de l'ouest
cellou dalien diallo s'est d'ailleurs
prêt auto proclamé vainqueur de la
présidentielle alors que le pays attend
toujours les résultats officiels france
pâtissier dietsch des barricades en feu
dans le quartier populaire de wanindara
à conakry la capitale
tout au long de la journée des jeunes
supporters de l'opposant guinéen cellou
dallen diallo se sont opposés aux forces
de l'ordre sur les réseaux sociaux
le président sortant alpha condé qui
brigue à 81,2 en un troisième mandat
controversé a lancé un nouvel appel au
calme
j'appelle chacun et tous au sens de la
responsabilité et au patriotisme pour
qu'il soit possible après cette élection
quels que soient les résultats de
construire ensemble la guinée sans
exclusion ni discrimination de personnes
de qu'une partie du pays
c'est ensemble que nous réussirons dans
un destin unie et solidaire
je le rappelle encore la guinée est au
dessus de tout le monde
protégeons la dimanche dernier les
électeurs ont pris d'assaut les bureaux
de vote jusqu'à leur fermeture
mais les guinéens sont depuis dans
l'expectative le lendemain
cellou dallen diallo le principal
opposant au président c'est d'ailleurs
proclamé vainqueur
à
les anomalies qui ont entaché le bon
déroulement du scrutin du 18 au taux est
en vie des résultats sortis des urnes
je sens pourtant selon les premiers
résultats du scrutin de la commission
électorale nationale
alpha condé donnés vainqueurs dans les
quatre circonscriptions sur 38 qui
composent le pays
le camp de l'opposition accuse de son
côté celui du chef de l'état de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour faire modifier les
résultats sortis des urnes en sa faveur
des élections qui se sont déroulées de
manière régulière
selon les chefs des missions
d'observation de l'union africaine et de
la cedeao et on en vient la situation au
karabagh dans le conflit qui oppose
l'arménie à l'azerbaïdjan le premier
ministre arménien a déclaré exclure
toute solution diplomatique il appelle
également ses concitoyens à se porter
volontaires au front pour combattre aux
côtés des séparatistes du haut karabagh
contre l'azerbaïdjan ce territoire le
haut karabagh valérie boyer déposera
cette semaine un texte au sénat visant à
reconnaître son indépendance et a
condamné les actions de l'azerbaïdjan et
de la turquie et la sénatrice les
républicains des bouches du rhône
explique sur sa page facebook que se
poser à l'avancé de l'azerbaïdjan au
haut karabagh c'est aussi s'opposer à
l'extension de l'islam turc à travers
l'europe et pour parler de ce texte
justement nous sommes avec valérie boyer
sénatrice les républicains des bouches
du rhône valérie boyer
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors étant le coprésident du
groupe de minsk
la france ne doit elle pas garder son
statut de neutralité pour permettre au
fond la résolution du conflit
hélas d'abord merci de m'interroger sur
cette question qui est éminemment
importante
et si vous me le permettez elle est
importante videmment pour le sud caucase
mais elle est importante aussi pour la
france elle est importante pour l'europe
parce que faire sauter le verrou du haut
karabagh puis après celui de l'arménie
c'est sûr que rien n'arrêtera la turquie
qui déjà jette des bases à chypre dans
les îles grecques puisque je rappelle
que cet été la turquie a survolé a violé
l'espace aérien et l'espace maritime
grecque sans qu'il y ait vraiment eu de
réaction ni de sanctions et des
réactions courageuse de la france et de
la grèce mais il n'y a pas eu de
sanction derrière dont c'est extrêmement
important
y compris j'allais dire pour notre unité
nationale et y compris face à la menace
terroriste qui malheureusement en deuil
la france alors à votre question doit-on
rester neutres ben je dirais des
semaines tout te disais que être neutre
c'est choisir son camp et est ce que la
france est ce que l'europe peuvent
choisir le camp de la barbarie est ce
que la france est ce que l'europe
tolérer qu'il y ait encore haut karabagh
qu'il y ait encore pour les arméniens du
haut-karabakh et d'arménie à nouveau
génocide
je rappelle que l'azerbaïdjan à attaquer
le haut karabagh et a attaqué également
l'arménie qui est un état souverain donc
on est bien dans une déclaration de
guerre totalement asymétrique et qui n'a
qu'une seule visée exterminer éradiquer
la population arménienne faire du
nettoyage ethnique et à nettoyage
culturel parce qu'on sait que
malheureusement en plus de tuer des
humains
l'azerbaïdjan et saïd effacer toutes les
traces de la présence arménienne qui est
pourtant ancestrale qui est qui date de
plusieurs siècles sur ce territoire qui
a toujours était arménien alors début
octobre jean yves le drian s'était
positionné en faveur de cette neutralité
la position du gouvernement est ce
qu'elle peut
évoluer selon vous cette neutralité elle
n'est ni responsable ni digne et surtout
elle est totalement inefficace
on n'en est pas à la neutralité en en et
aux massacres de populations civiles
je rappelle quand même que le
haut-karabakh c'est à peu près
l'équivalent de la ville de nice et que
l'arménie c'est deux millions deux
millions et demi d'habitants donc on est
et que le budget militaire de
l'azerbaïdjan il est largement
supérieure au budget total de l'arménie
et que l'azerbaïdjan en l'occurrence est
le bras armé de la turquie dans cette
affaire et que se passe-t-il
ça fait des mois et des mois que
monsieur erdogan pour masquer ses échecs
intérieurs ses échecs économiques et
même politiques et surtout après le coup
d'état de 2016 essaye de se trouver une
issue international sa à commencer par
la libye et puis ensuite il ya eu les à
chypre ou à chypre où il avance des
pions quand même chypre est un détail
d'union européenne il avance des pions
sans que rien ne se passe ça a commencé
aussi ça continue avec les menaces
vis-à-vis des grecs le massacre au
kurdistan
l'attitude plus qu'en bibal en devoir
dire complice avec les djihadistes lors
de la guerre de syrie et là nous avons
de véritables attaques avec des
djihadistes d'ailleurs qui qui sont
lâchés contre les populations
arméniennes donc on voit bien les
intentions absolument belliqueuse de la
turquie et de l'azerbaïdjan parce que
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre l'un agit
pour le compte de l'autre vis-à-vis de
l'arménie
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui recep
tayyip erdogan et imane al y est certes
souhaite s'offrir en trophée le
haut-karabakh fui l'arménie dont très
nette de toute façon pour vous en jeu
malheureusement ils n'ont jamais caché
leurs intentions ils le disent de façon
tout à fait clair et je rappelle quand
même que ceux qui s'intéressent à cette
question hante en mémoire les pogroms
anti-arméniens des années 1990 donc pour
vous aujourd'hui la france voit
clairement ce dress
aujourd'hui pour vous la france doit
clairement se dresser devant l'
influence grandissante de la turquie
par quelle voie par voie diplomatique je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs voies la
première c'est la voie diplomatique et
il est urgent de reconnaître l'état
indépendant d'axa
ça fait 30 ans que les accords de mix
piétine et il faut le faire en urgence
pourquoi parce que seule la
reconnaissance d'un état indépendant ce
qui glay dans les faits depuis 30 ans
parce que c'est une démocratie en plus
il ya permettrait de protéger ces
populations
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est également d'envoyer des
troupes internationales au sol sous
mandat de l'onu on ne peut pas laisser
cette population est totalement massacré
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
je rappelle quand même que l'azerbaïdjan
utilisent des armes non conventionnelles
vis-à-vis de populations civiles qui
sont déjà dans un dénuement important et
là c'est encore plus ils visent des
églises ils visent des hôpitaux ils
lisent des écoles il envoie quand même
des barbares djihadistes contre ses
populations
donc on est dans une urgence humanitaire
et se taire c'est peut-être du côté des
barbares et aujourd'hui je pense que la
france ne peut pas l'être
la france ne peut pas l'être parce que
c'est son devoir historique de d'abord
d'aider les peuples qui veulent disposer
d'eux mêmes c'est le cas des arméniens
du haut-karabakh
c'est aussi son devoir de mémoire
vis-à-vis des rescapés du génocide de
1915 perpétré par lecture que qui ont
trouvé refuge en france comme dans plein
pays dans plein de pays au monde mais en
france puisque nous sommes en france et
que nous en parlons c'est son devoir
parce qu'elle est membre du groupe de
mix et c'est son devoir aussi puisque
elle veut peser ce dans le concert des
nations
et aujourd'hui ça l'est d'autres fois je
me faisais la réflexion et je pensais
lorsque nicolas sarkozy était présent de
la république qu'il y avait eu des
conflits
en janvier il n'avait pas hésité à se
déplacer pourquoi emmanuel macron navire
est il pas un ancien premier ministre et
un ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères une personne eu un ancien
président de la république pour pour
pour faire en sorte que les nations
européennes à l'image de l'autriche qui
a pris une résolution par exemple est
bien seul hic pour dire stop aux
exactions turkson stop aux menaces turcs
parce qu'ici il ya une chose qu'on peut
pas reprocher à monsieur erdogan sait ne
pas annoncer la couleur
et malheureusement il fait ce qui lui
dit merci
ce qui est vraiment dramatique en amont
la font toujours l europe laissent faire
merci beaucoup
valérie boyer d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains elle des
bouches-du-rhône et c'est la fin de
cette émission mais restez avec nous on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes un héros pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire les
expéditions se trouve ça parce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on va bien on l'a 37 quand
on a un degré de plus de 38 en médecine
à blaesheim fabrique une petite fièvre
couvre quelque chose la planète l année
là aujourd'hui chacun dans ses activités
impact la nature impacte notre les
questions environnementales
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique
jean jaurès 10ème une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal quittant
comprenant le réel
[Musique]